«آيهرب» كانوا جايين المملكة العربية السعودية
وتواصلوا مع وزارة التجارة ومع الدكتور «ماجد»
والدكتورة «إيمان» معالي نائب وزير التجارة
كلموني وقالوا: لازم تدعم تواجدهم وتشوف أيش يحتاجون
أخذتهم على مدينة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية
وقلت لهم: هنا بيكون فيه منطقة حرة، واحنا عارفين أنها جاية
وفيه في الجنب الرياض هذه المنطقة الحرة الثانية
قال لي المسؤول: احنا مبيعاتنا في المملكة العربية السعودية
أكثر من مبيعاتنا في أمريكا
واو!
70% من حجم المبيعات في المنطقة كلها في المملكة
و70% من حجم مبيعاتنا في المملكة في الرياض
فأي شيء غير الرياض؛ لا توريني
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية
وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو المهندس «لؤي مشعبي»
وكيل وزارة النقل والخدمات اللوجستية للخدمات اللوجستية
أعتبر هذه الحلقة حلقة التربيط
عندنا يمكن أربع أو خمس حلقات في القطاع اللوجستي
حلقة عن الموانئ، حلقة عن النقل
حلقة عن البريد، حلقة عن الطيران المدني
هذه الحلقة هي لتربيط هذه القطاعات المختلفة
وهذا يُنشئ لنا شيء اسمه القطاع اللوجستي
أيش أبرز ما حققناه الفترة الماضية في هذا القطاع؟
أيش مفهوم الربط بين هذه القطاعات المختلفة؟
أيش علاقته بالمخطط العام للمراكز اللوجستية؟
وبعد كل هذا المشهد، سولفنا عن الممر الاقتصادي
اللي أُعلن عنه مؤخرًا وتكامله مع طريق «الحزام والحرير»
اللي تتبناها الصين
وكيف السعودية تستفيد من هذه كلها؟
تكلمنا عن الجسر البري، عن الربط السككي مع الخليج
وكل هذه التفاصيل؛ أسهب ضيفنا في الحديث عنها
من زاوية علاقتها بالقطاع اللوجستي
وليش هذا القطاع مهم وجوهري
لدرجة أنه كان الركيزة الثالثة من ركائز الرؤية
من أول يوم أُطلقت رؤية السعودية 2030
كان محور ربط القارات هو الركيزة الثالثة
فأترككم مع حوار ثري ودسم عن القطاع اللوجستي
حيّاك الله أبو عمر، شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يحييك، سعيد بتواجدي معكم
أبو عمر أنت كسرت رقم قياسي عندنا
أنا أصحابي لما يبغون يسخرون مني أو يتنمرون علي
يقولون: أنت أي أحد تستضيفه؛ يُعفى
وأنا أقول لهم: لا، يمكن يترقى طيب!
بس في كل الأحوال؛ هو يتغير منصب أغلب ضيوفنا
بعد فترة قصيرة
أنت ما شاء الله منصبك تغيّر قبل ما تُنشر الحلقة
عشان كذا ما جيتك إلا وأنا خلاص
خالص
وين المحطة الجاية؟
والله داخل المنظومة
أنا لي فترة في مجلس إدارة السعودية للشحن
وكان فيه حديث من فترة أني أنتقل معهم
وفيه تنسيق مع معالي الوزير بالتوقيت الأنسب لذلك
فإن شاء الله راح أنتقل للسعودية للشحن
اللي تملك 70% منها الخطوط السعودية
اللي يرأس مجلس إدارتها معالي الوزير
فما زلت في المنظومة
بس طبعًا هم عندهم هدف طموح كبير جدًّا المرحلة القادمة
أكثر من تضاعف في حجم الطائرات والوصول إلى دول أكثر
وبالتالي المرحلة القادمة مختلفة شوي عن المرحلة الحالية
وأتمنى أني أتوفّق في مساعدتهم في الوصول إلى هذه الأهداف
قبل ما ندخل في موضوع حلقتنا اللي هو عن القطاع اللوجستي
ودي أسولف معك على ملف
يهمني أفتحه مع أغلب القادة
اللي هو إدارة الضغط
كثير من قادة التحول الفترة الماضية
يعيشون ضغط استثنائي في وقتهم، في صحتهم
نتيجة المهام الجسيمة اللي هم يقومون فيها
أنت يبدو لي عندك تجربة مثيرة في هذا الموضوع
كيف قاعد تدير الضغط؟
أنا بطبعي هادي جدًّا جدًّا
لأني اشتغلت فترة طويلة كمهندس بترول
ونشتغل في الصحراء ومسؤولين على أرواح ناس
المخاطر كبيرة
وتعودت في أي حالة خاصة إستنائية
يكون عندي هدوء كبير وتركيز على حل المشكلة
لكن مع ذلك المسؤولية كبيرة
والقطاع اللوجستي مثل غيره لا يُستثنى من ذلك
وحس المسؤولية يخلي الواحد ما وده يقصّر في شيء
بعدين تشوف كل اللي فوقك يشتغلون أكثر منك
أصحاب المعالي الوزراء تشوفهم
تقول: المفروض أنا أشتغل أكثر
وتشوف بعدين سمو سيدي
تقول: المفروض احنا نشتغل أكثر منه
فهذا الضغط طبعًا موجود
فأنا كنت محافظ على الرياضة بشكل كبير طول حياتي
أنا مدرب غوص، أركب خيل، أسوق قوارب
أسبح بشكل كبير وكنت في فريق «أرامكو» لكرة الماء
وفي الجامعة كنت في منتخب الجامعة للكرة
عندي حب وشغف للرياضة كبير متابعةً وممارسةً
الحقيقة لما دخلت بعد أول أربعة شهور
توقّفت فترة عن الرياضة، لأن ما عاد فيه وقت
وحتى لو فيه وقت؛ يكون فيك من هاجس التفكير الشيء الكبير
حتى والله مع أهلي
لما أجلس مع الأولاد وللا مع زوجتي؛ ما كأني موجود
ذهنك في مكان ثاني
ذهني في مكان ثاني، لأن فيه كثير ملفات
وين تبدأ ووين تنتهي،
وما ودك تقصيرك هو اللي أدى أنه ما تم الملف
الين ما صارت معي حادثة
أن كلما أمسك شيء؛ يجيني تنميل شديد في اليد
وخفت، ما أدري أيش القصة
وبفحص سريع طلع نقص في فيتامين «باء»
الحمد لله الله وفقني وزوجتي طبيبة أسرة ذات خبرة طويلة
وقالت لي: أتوقع فيتامين «باء»
وفعلًا طلع فيتامين «باء»
قالت لي: أنصحك...
وهذه معلومة أعتقد أنها مثيرة
في الغوص الحر أنت تعرف أنك تحتاج إلى أكسجين
لما يزداد نسبة ثاني أكسيد الكربون
مو لما ينقص الأكسجين
فاللي يغوصون كثير
ممكن جسمهم يتعوّد على نسبة ثاني أكسيد الكربون عالية
فيغرقون، لأن ما جاهم الإحساس أنهم لازم يتنفسون
وهذا نفس الشيء، إذا أنت معتاد على الظروف الصعبة
فيبان عليك الهدوء، ويبان على فريقك الهدوء
لكن أحيانًا أنت ما تعرف
من جوّا قاعد تحترق
أنك من جوّا تحترق
أنت تشعر أن عندك تحكّم
الين ما -سبحان الله- جسمك يعطيك إشارة
أنه لا، ما عندك تحكّم
فيه تحدي أكبر من قدرتك الطبيعية على التحمل
فهذا يمكن كان هو الإشارة
وعملت الفحوصات؛ وفعلًا لقيت الكوليسترول مرتفع بشكل كبير
وأنا ما زال جسمي محافظ
دهون في الكبد، ما كانت متوقعة في حالتي هذه ووزني هذا
والحمد لله من بعدها ركزت أكثر على الأكل
وأصريت أني أرجع أسبح يوميًا
بغض النظر عن الظروف
فالسباحة ربع ساعة مو بأكثر، لكنها بسرعة عالية
وفعلًا نزل، الرقم الضار كان وصل إلى 160
المفروض يكون 130
الآن وصلت إلى تحت الـ 140
إن شاء الله نرجعه إلى 130
ما شاء الله
بالنسبة لي الرياضة كانت جزء أساسي
النقطة الثانية، صرت بشكل كبير أعتمد على الفريق
وبيسمعوا الحلقة وهم بيعرفون
صار كل واحد منهم اللي ماسك ملفات
صار عنده مساحة أكبر بكثير لقيادة الملف
وإن لم يكن تمامًا على هواي
لكن أعتقد...
اللي فهمت أن طبيعة عمل الوزير «الجاسر»
ساعدتك في أنك ترجع للرياضة
لأن ساعات العمل نوعًا ما محدودة
على العكس أغلب اللي شغالين في الحكومة ما في حدود للوقت
مثل ما تعرف القطاع اللوجستي يشتغل مع كل الوزراء بشكل مباشر
فأعرفهم كلهم بشكل قريب
وعلاقتي فيهم الحمد لله دائمًا ممتازة
معالي «الجاسر» فعلًا، مو بس معالي «الجاسر»
حتى منظومة أعتقد، شوف المنظومة النقل في نظري
القيادات اللي فيها
أنت قابلت «عمر حريري» وفيها معالي «الدعيج» ومعالي «الرميح»
كلهم عملهم مؤسسي أكثر مما هو يعتمد على الشخص
والزمن راح يكون دليل على ذلك
حتى بعد انتقالهم راح تشوف أن فيه استمرارية كبيرة
لأن أشوف في طريقة العمل اعتماد كثير
على العمل المؤسسي، بناء الكفاءات
مش الصف الأول والصف الثاني
اتخاذ القرار لازم يمر بكل المسارات
هو متعب بالذات وأنت قاعد تبني الكفاءات
تعيد من تعريف المنظومة
لكن أنا أعتقد على المدى الطويل صحي جدًّا
ومعالي «أبو نواف» 7:00 الصباح في المكتب
معالي «الرميح» 7:00 صباح في المكتب
اجتماعات من 8:00 - 4:00
90% من الوقت
نادرا جدًّا لما يكون الاجتماع يرتبط بمركز الحكومة أو الديوان
أو ملف خارج منظومتنا
هي اللي تكون الاجتماعات المسائية اللي هي 8:00
فأنت بعد 4:00 في البيت مع عيالك
نعم
6:00 في المسبح
نعم، 4:00 أكون في البيت، أتغذى مع أهلي وأقعد معهم إلى المغرب
بعد المغرب أطلع للسباحة
ومن السباحة أطلع للاستراحة
الاستراحة ترى نصها اجتماعات
كل موظفين الحكومة
فيها أربع وكلاء وزراء، وفيها كل أحد
نخلّص شغلنا واحنا هناك
لكن كثير مننا تلاقي حاط السماعة أصلًا
واللابتوب في يده ونكمل أعمالنا
ترى أنام الساعة 10:00
ما شاء الله
أو أخرج من الاستراحة، 10:00 أو 10:30 أنا نايم كل يوم
5:30 أنا صاحي كل يوم
ما أذكر أني شغّلت المنبّه آخر عشر سنوات
إلا لو عندي رحلة دولية
غير كذا ما أذكر أني شغلت منبّه
«أرامكو» عاد تربيت على هذا الأساس
وهذه إلى الآن ماشية معك بشكل جيد
في ضبط الضغط، في موضوع الكوليسترول
حاليًا كافية هذه الخطوات
الحمد لله آخر الفحوصات كلها تحسنت الأرقام
ما شاء الله
وإن شاء الله تستمر فيه
قدامك العافية يا رب
احنا سعداء «أبو عمر» نكسبك ضيف
في ملف مرة مهم، في توقيت مهم
اللي هو القطاع اللوجستي
عندنا أكثر من ضيف سابقًا غطّوه من زاويتهم
فمعالي «الرميح» الموانئ، الطيران المدني
ففيه أكثر من ضيف غطّوا قطاعات جزئية
اليوم نبغى نشوف الصورة الكبيرة للقطاع اللوجستي
وممكن نبدأ بداية سريعة في شرح أيش هو القطاع؟
قبل ما ندخل على التحوّل اللي صاير فيه
ممتاز، ميزة القطاع أنه يتقاطع مع كل أحد
يتقاطع مع الصناعة والسياحة والتعدين
وفيه صراحة معرفة بشكل جيد
من منظورات مختلفة من كل الجهات
فلذلك لما تتكلم عنه؛ تجد الكل عنده رأي وعنده فكر
وهذا شيء جيد في هذا القطاع
احنا المملكة العربية السعودية...
وتعريفه بالأكاديميين، شوف ترى اختلافات...
لا ما نبي الأكاديميين، الأكاديميين بيعقدونها
أنا أبي تعريف مبسّط أي أحد يقدر يفهمه
أيش تعريف القطاع اللوجستي؟
الخدمات اللوجستية كل ما يخص نقل البضائع
إلى المملكة، من المملكة عبر المنافذ، أو داخل المملكة
سواءً كانت هذه البضاعة كبيرة، حاويات
سواءً كانت سائبة، سواءً كانت مواشي
أو سواءً كانت محطة التوصيل الأخيرة
برًّا، بحرًا، جوًّا، سككيًّا، تخزينًا هذا كله يقع تحت...
فحركة البضائع من المنشأ إلى المستفيد النهائي
بكل وسائطها: سككي، بحري، جوّي
كلها هذه تعتبر قطاع لوجستي
حتى بما فيها مرحلة التخزين
المستودعات وإعادة التغليف، وإعادة التصدير وإلى آخره
100%
كلها قطاع لوجستي؟
نعم
اشرح لنا هذا القطاع المهم
ليش احنا كنا غايبين عنه؟
مع أن تاريخيًّا احنا معبر التجارة بين آسيا وإفريقيا وأوربا
بس إلى وقت إطلاق الرؤية
واحنا تقريبًا خارج المشهد اللوجستي
فعلًا، شوف لو تطالع حولك
وهذا كلام حتى من القيادة نسمعه
نطالع حولنا، أنت عندك في الشمال: العراق، سوريا، لبنان، فلسطين
عندك في الشرق: إيران
عندك في الجنوب: اليمن
عندك في الغرب: شرق إفريقيا، إثيوبيا، السودان، جيبوتي
كلها فيها من المكامن ومن الفرص
أن اقتصادها ينهض الشيء الكثير
واحنا دورنا نستغل
صحيح احنا بين ثلاث قارات دائمًا نقول ونربط الشرق بالغرب
لكن الساحة اللي فعلًا ممكن تكون ذو أثر كبير
يتضاعف عشرات الأضعاف من الأحجام الحالية
هي بنهضة الدول اللي حولنا
لذلك تلاقي سمو سيدي في كل محضر
يقول: شرق أوسط، وأوربا الجديدة
وحتى في التوجيهات اللي تجينا من الوزراء
اللي أكيد سمعوها منه
تروح الدولة حتى لو هم ما هم بجهازين يستقبلون
حتى لو التعاون لسه ماهو على أعلى مستوى
تروح مرة واثنين وثلاثة وأربعة وتساهم في ذلك
العُرف عندنا هو الاستيراد
والاستيراد ما يتأثر بكفاءة المنفذ
تأثير كفاءة المنفذ على الاستيراد ما تتجاوز 3%
سواءً فسحته في ثمانية أيام وللا في يوم
ما يؤثر على وزن الاستيراد بشكل كبير
على التصدير كفاءة المنفذ تأثر 10%
على إعادة التصدير 70% أو 80%
هذه اللعبة اللي ما كانت محل اهتمام من قبلنا
أعتقد أحد الأسباب الأخرى هو وجود مركز قريب مننا
نجح في أنه يوصل لنا البضاعة بشكل ممتاز
اللي هي دبي
كثير من المنتجات ما في إمكانية تجي بشكل مباشر
لو تروح لبلد المنشأ ما يقدر يصنع شيء ويناسب 190 أو 200 دولة
هو يسوي له مراكز حول العالم
سنقافورة، دبي، هولندا وغيرها
وهذيك المراكز هي اللي تصنع ما يوازي
اللي تحتاجه الدول في المنطقة ويوزع لها
فمن غير وجود المركز، حتى لو كانت منافذنا على كفاءة عالية
ما كان كثير من البضائع وصلت بالتنوع هذا ولا بالرخص هذا
فاحنا أيضًا وجود...
أعطيك مثال، لما زرنا كوريا
معظم تجارة اليابان عبر الموانئ الكورية، وراضين هم
هم بالنسبة لهم قانعين بهذا الموضوع
فلذلك أعتقد ما كانت محل...
المشكلة كانت مُحلّة بشكل أو بآخر
بوجود شريك قوي بالقرب منا
وما كانت محل الاهتمام أن يكون لنا دور أكبر على هذا المحور
واليوم أيش مشروعنا اللوجستي؟
مشروعنا اللوجستي هو الدول اللي حولنا
لوجستيًا نكون سبب في دعم نهضتها لفتح هذا الباب
نكون إحدى أفضل عشر دول في الأداء اللوجستي
وعلى مستوى حجم الحاويات تقريبًا أربعة أضعاف
على مستوى الوزن اللي ننقله جوًّا تقريبًا أربعة أضعاف
تقريبًا نتكلم على أربعة أضعاف حجم تعامل البضائع برًّا وبحرًا
أيش بيفرق معانا لما نوصل لهذه الأرقام؟
ليش ما نستمر على النموذج السابق؟
بضائعنا قاعدة تجي وصادراتنا قاعدة تصير
ليش محتاج أنا أنشّط القطاع اللوجستي في السعودية؟
رقم واحد، حتى الوارد راح يستفيد
اليوم معظم الحاويات تجي مليئة وتخرج فارغة
وهذا يرفع التكلفة
يرفع التكلفة بالضعف
الطائرات، أنا في مجلس الإدارة السعودية للشحن، أمون عليهم
معامل الحمل في الوارد للمملكة مليان 95%
لو نبسطها،  أيش هو معامل الحمل؟
اللي هو قد أيش الطائرة معبّاية
فالطائرات الواردة للمملكة تقريبًا 95% أو 96%
أعلى من المعدل العالمي
وحتى الـ 4% اللي باقية عشان توزيع الأوزان
ليس بسبب أن ما فيه...
الخارج 30%
فهذه مساحة مهدرة
أول فائدة هي خفض التكاليف
لما ترفع الترانزيت وترفع الصادرات وترفع إعادة التصدير
تصير الحاويات تخرج
أول شيء الطائرات تطلع مليانة
ينقسم تكلفة الشحن إلى النصف
هذا المكسب الأول
هذا رقم واحد
رقم اثنين، مما لا شك فيه
أن لو كانت العمليات الإضافية تكون على شواطئك
إذا أنت 70% من سوق هذه الشركات عندك
برضه توصل لك أرخص
الآن مهما قارنت فيها، إذا راحت دولة أخرى وبعدين شُحنت لنا
أغلى من لو كانت جاتنا احنا وبعدين شحنت لنا
واحنا سوق كبير
فهذا سبب ثاني يخلينا نركز حتى على المناطق الحرة
السبب الثالث، القوة الناعمة
حتى تذكر جائحة كورونا يكون عندك على أراضيك
عدد كبير من الأدوية، عدد كبير من المصانع
أنا أعطيك مثال راح نتطرق له بعدين بشكل أكبر
المنطقة الحرة في «جيزان» عندنا
بجانبها ميناء «هاتشوس» وهو ميناء شركة هونق كونق صينية
معظم المصانع اللي فيه أيش؟ صينيين
راح تستورد المواد الخام من إفريقيا
على مصانع صينية في المنطقة الحرة بـ«جيزان»
وبعدين راح تصدرها إلى باقي العالم
كل هذه المصانع ما صارت قوة ناعمة لك؟
صار عندك في المفاوضات، ووزنك الدولي؛ إلا
فلذلك أعتقد على مستوى المساهمة في الناتج المحلي
على مستوى تخفيض الأسعار على المستهلك السعودي
وعلى مستوى القوة الناعمة المملكة كلها انتصارات
لو بنمسكها هي أربعة أجزاء نوعًا ما رئيسية
نتكلم عن قطاع السكك، قطاع الموانئ، الطيران
والقطاع البري اللي هو الشاحنات
هل نقدر نمر بشكل سريع
أيش كان أبرز ما تحقق في كل واحد من هذولي؟
أول خليني أشرح، لأن كثير من المستخدمين
عندهم أسئلة عن علاقة الوزارة بالهيئة
وليش فيه هيئات كثير؟
خلني أشرح المنظومة، ومنها نتطرق إلى القطاعات
الوزارة هي اللي تنظر للسياسة العامة والأهداف العامة
احنا نبغى عدد الحاويات كذا
احنا نبغى رضا المستفيدين كذا، نبغى مؤشرنا كذا
وتُنزل هذه استراتيجية النقل والخدمات اللوجستية
تم إسقاطها على الجهات التنفيذية
الجهات التنفيذية هي اللي تطلّع التراخيص
هي اللي عندها الرقابة في الأسواق
هي اللي عندها اللوائح والضبط
هي اللي عندها المخالفات
الوزارة لا تقوم بذلك
هذا كله تقوم فيه هيئات مستقلة
الموانئ مسؤولة عن الموانئ
الهيئة العامة للنقل على كل ما يخص النقل
بما في ذلك النقل البحري حاليًا
والهيئة العامل للطيران، أيضًا المطارات والنقل الجوي عندها
فهذه طريقة عمل الأجهزة المختلفة
وطبعًا المؤسسة العامة البريد فيما يخص البريد
فهذه طريقة علاقة الوزارة بالجهات
وبعدين الجهات بالقطاع الخاص
وأثر الوزارة على الجهات هذه
كل برامج الرؤية والتحوّل
لازم يمر بالوزارة قبل ما نروح لمركز الحكومة
ففيه تنسيق وتأثير من الوزارة على الجهات المستقلة
بمعزل من كون رئيس مجلس إدارة هذه الجهات كلها
هو معالي وزير النقل
الدولة انتقلت من الأجهزة الكثيرة المستقلة إلى المنظومات
كانت كل واحدة جهاز مستقل ومجلس إدارة مستقل
الآن توجهت إلى وجود منظومة الصناعة
منظومة الاتصالات، منظومة النقل
هذا توجّه للدولة
بعدين اللي ينسّق بين هذه المنظومات: برامج الرؤية
برنامج «ندلب» اللي فيه الصناعة والتعدين
والطاقة والخدمات اللوجستية
فيه مجلس إدارة وفيه تلاقي معالي «السواح»
ومعالي «الخريّف» ومعالي «الجاسر»
اللي هم وزير الصناعة والاتصالات
يجلسون في غرفة وحدة، لأن قطاعاتهم تتقاطع بشكل كبير
فهذه آلية العمل
وهناك لجنة عليا للخدمات اللوجستية يرأسها سمو سيدي
تمامًا مثل الشركات
هذه مؤشرات قياس الأداء
نروح نعرض عليه كل المؤشرات وين وصلنا فيه
إذا عملنا مهمة ممتازة؛ يمدح ويشكر
ممكن يرفع وصارت أكثر من مرة
رفع المستهدف طالما حققناه بشكل مبكر
وإذا ما عملنا؛ إذا كان هناك دعم
يصير يسأل أيش الدعم؟
أيش التحدي اللي صار عشان نحله؟
وإذا كان فيه تقصير؛ يكون فيه توجيه مباشر بتجاوز هذا التقصير
أنا جاي من القطاع الخاص معظم عمري
تمامًا مثل محضر اجتماع حق شركة
ويضع عليك مسؤولية أنك تكون دائمًا جاهز ودائمًا تؤدي
أنا أتكلم عن البضائع، الركاب ما لي علاقة فيه
فبالنسبة للبضائع خلينا ننظر على قطاع، قطاع
وقفني محل...
هل المخطط اللوجستي يربط بينهم كلهم؟
وللا هو يخص قطاع معين؟
المراكز اللوجستية هي تنفع الجميع
ففيه مراكز لوجستية في المطارات
ودك نبدأ فيها وللا ودك نخليها آخر شيء؟
إيه، آخر شيء
عشان الربط بينهم
إيه الربط بينهم
بتبدأ من وين؟
الموانئ هي أسهل
وحتى قصتنا في الموانئ ممتازة جدًّا
في أكثر من مؤشر دولي تكون موانئ المملكة من أعلى عشرة
على كفاءة التشغيل، على سرعة تحوّل الحاوية
كانت الحصة السوقية في الترانزيت
اللي ينزل في المملكة بشكل بسيط ومن ثم يطلع
أعتقد 12% أو حولها
اليوم فوق 30% في سنتين، بس تغيير تشريعات
كل شهر تسمع رقم قياسي جديد في الموانئ السعودية
والمؤشرات العالمية حتى الـ«بي آي» لما طلع
ترتيبك بين الدول بناءً على الخدمة
لكن فيه في التقرير تلاقي
الدرجة؟
كم معدل انتظار السفينة؟
كم معدل انتظار الحاوية إلى دخولها؟
كلها احنا من الأوائل، إن لم نكن الأول في المنطقة
حتى لو قارنتنا بتركيا أو بالإمارات
احنا أسرع في (...)* الحاوية
حتى في الاتصال؛ وجود الخطوط المباشرة
بين موانئ المملكة وبين الموانئ الأخرى
كانت طبعًا المركز الأول للإمارات بالتأكيد
كان الفارق في التقرير الماضي يمكن 12% أو 13% نقطة
اليوم الفارق 1.5%
هذا في الـ«إل بي آي»
في تقرير الـ«إل بي آي» يشيرون إلى ربط موانئك بالخطوط المباشرة
الآن نحن الفارق نقطة أو نقطة ونص بيننا وبين الإمارات
وعندي ثقة كبيرة أن قبل التقرير القادم بنكون...
لأن كل المشاريع هذه تزيد من إمكانية الاتصال
وأيضًا تشريعات الموانئ تغيّرت
على الترانزيت تغيرت
وأصبحت كل عقود الشركات المشغلة عقود مبنية على الأداء
أول كانت العقود في الموانئ
والله أبغى كذا رافعة وكذا حاوية
الآن لا، لازم الحاوية ما تقعد أكثر من ساعتين
إذا قعدت أكثر من ساعتين؛ عليك غرامة
لازم التكلفة ما ترتفع عن القيمة الفلانية
إذا ارتفعت؛ فعليك...
فصار التشريعات يسموها اقتصادية كبيرة
تحفّز المشغلين على سرعة الأداء ورفع مستوى الخدمة
هذا صار من سنتين والآن نحن نشوف نتائجه بشكل كبير
أيش اللي ينقص الموانئ؟
تكامل الخدمات
عادةً السفينة الكبيرة إذا جات الميناء
تبغى تنزل كل أنواع الحاويات
سواءً حاوية كاملة، أو حاوية فيها أكثر من عميل
أو يبغاها في منطقة حرة
أو يبغى يسوي عليها خدمات إضافية
هذا هو اللي عليه عمل
لذلك في عام 2024 راح ينطلق نظام «بانكرينق»
ونظام تعبئة وقود كبير في «ينبع»
«بانكرينق» اللي هو؟
اللي هو لصيانة السفن وزيادة تزويدها بالخدمات اللي تحتاجها
وتعبئة وقود
فيصير اللي جاي على ميناء جدة الإسلامي
إذا موعده بعد يوم، يومين
يقدر يوقّف في «ينبع»
يعمل الصيانة اللي يحتاجها والتنظيف ويعبئ البنزين وغيرها
هذه خدمة مهمة ترفع من حركة المرور اللي تجيك
المناطق الحرة: مدينة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية الآن
و«جيزان» على البحر الأحمر و«رأس الخير» على الخليج
تعطيك خدمات القيمة المضافة
معناه إذا جاتك سفينة كبيرة
وبعض عملاءها ودهم يحطون حاويتهم ويسوون عليها أعمال
يكون موجود هذه الخدمة
فاللي ينقص الموانئ كان هو الخدمات
وليس كفاءة عمل الموانئ ولا تشريعاتها، هذا انتهى
والآن مع بداية المناطق الحرة؛ راح تشوف الأثر خلال سنتين
عاد لما تبدأ المستودعات تعمل؛ ما عندي شك
حتى صديق لي عُماني عندهم خمس موانئ وخمس مناطق حرة
يقول لي: الميناء يشيل المناطق الحرة سنتين
على ما تبنيها وتكبرها وتبدأ المستودعات
المنطقة الحرة خسرانة والميناء هو اللي يدخل شوية دخل
بعد سنتين أو ثلاثة؛ المنطقة الحرة هي اللي تشغّل الميناء
من غيرها وزن الميناء ينقص بشكل كبير
وهذا ما بيكون استثناء عندنا...
إذا تسمح لي أوقّفك هنا ما دام تكلمت عن الموانئ والمناطق الحرة
أنت ذكرت «رابغ» و«جيزان» و«رأس الخير»
وهذه كانت بالنسبة لي ملفتة للنظر
أننا ركزنا على الموانئ الجديدة الصغيرة
في مقابل أن أكبر ميناء عندنا
اللي يمثل مجمل حركتنا التجارية اللي هو ميناء جدة
وهذا ما فيه نفس تكامل الخدمات
اللي يصير في الموانئ الصغيرة الجديدة هذه
ملاحظة في محلها 100%
طبعًا قصة ميناء «جيزان» محددة وصناعية
وراح تنجح لأنها محددة وواضحة
«رأس الخير» أيضًا صناعة السفن
ولها دراسة جدوى محدد راح تنجح فيه
من المناطق الحرة الحالية أكثر واحد فيهم عنده بعد لوجستي
هو ميناء الملك عبدالله في مدينة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية
ليش؟
لأنه مساحة كبيرة، وفيه مشاريع لزيادة الطاقة الاستيعابية
لهذا الميناء بشكل كبير
وقريب جدًّا من مراكز اقتصادية من مكة وجدة وغيرها
وهذا مناسب للشركات
وبنجي للربط السككي اللي يكمّل هذه القصة لما نوصل للسكك
فهذه يمكن أكبر واحدة
لكن ما في شك أن مينائي الملك عبدالعزيز في «الدمام»
وميناء جدة الإسلامي
بحاجة إلى مناطق حرة في كليهما
ليش ما صار فيها؟
اثنينهم تمت الموافقة من هيئة المدن الاقتصادية
على إنشاء مناطق حرة
لكن المدن الكبيرة حتى الرياض، الثلاثة المدن الكبيرة
فيها مخطط عام كبير يُحسم وينتهي حاليًا
فاحنا مثلًا متفقين مع هيئة تطوير جدة ومع هيئة المدن الاقتصادية
على منطقة حرة في جدة
«فيز 1» 2.4 مليون متر مربع، و«فيز 2» 10 مليون
لكن انتهاء من تفاصيل ذلك وإعلانه
يعتمد على المخطط
بيكون يعتمد على المخطط
لما نقول منطقة حرة أيش فرقها عن المناطق الأخرى؟
هي فيه منطقة عادية ومنطقة إيداع ومنطقة حرة
العادية هي المستودعات الطبيعية
منطقة إيداع: البضاعة اللي فيها عليها إعفاء على البضاعة
إعفاء جمركي، معلّقة جمركيًا
فتدخل البضاعة وتخرج، ما تدفع عليها «في إيه تي»
ما تدفع عليها تعرفة جمركية
وممكن تسوي خدمات
من الطرائف كنا نجيب ثلاجات من نفس المصنع، ستة
وبعدين نحط عليها «هاس» ونحط عليها شركات مختلفة
هو مصنع واحد يصنّع لكل هذه العلامات التجارية
فيستوردوها هذه الشركات مرة واحدة
وبعدين احنا كنا في منطقة الإيداع
نحط الملصق الصحيح وملصق كفاءة الطاقة
وبعدين نغلفها مرة ثانية وبعدين تفسح تدخل البلد
فمنطقة الإيداع قبل التفتيش الجمركي
معلّقة من التفتيش الجمركي والإعفاء على البضاعة
المنطقة الحرة الإعفاء يتجاوز البضاعة
الإعفاء على الشركة، الشركة ما تدفع ضريبة الشركات
ضريبة الشركات
ضريبة الشركات أو ضريبة الحوالات الخارجية
كلها تكون معلّقة على مستوى الشركة وليش فقط...
البضائع معلّقة أيضًا، لكنها على مستوى...
«جبل علي» يعتبر منطقة حرة؟
منطقة حرة
فالشركات اللي فيه ما تدفع ضريبة ولا تدفع رسوم
نعم، بس هناك الوضع مختلف
طبعًا الإمارات فيها يمكن ستة وعشرين منطقة حرة
بس هم حتى الاقتصاد الأساس إلى وقتٍ قريب
ما كان فيه ضرائب
كنوع من التقريب، اشرح لنا الآن الفرق بين
مناطق الإيداع والمناطق الحرة
اللي في الإمارات هي مناطق حرة
ما دمنا في موضوع الموانئ، أتذكر حلقة مع «خالد البواردي»
هو في مجلس التنسيق اللوجستي بين القطاع الخاص وبين الحكومة
وكان ذكر أكثر من تحدي، وأثنى على جهود معينة
فاللي مهتم في الحلقة يرجع لها
لكن أذكر أنه تكلم كثيرًا على موضوع التكلفة
وتكلفة المناطق القريبة من الموانئ
هو استثمر وبدأ في دبي
وبعدين انتقل للاستثمار في السعودية
فعنده قدرة على المقارنة بين التجربتين
يقول: سعر المتر لا يقارن
أنت بادي جديد، أنت تبغى تنشئ صناعة
هناك كان فيه حوافز عالية، سعر المتر اثنا عشر درهم
وبعدين ارتفع مع الوقت الين وصل لأرقام سعر السوق تقريبًا
بس بعد ما نضجت الصناعة وجذبوا الناس
وجابوا الحركة للمكان
يقول: احنا لا، الأراضي القريبة من الموانئ غالية جدًّا
نعم
وغير جاذبة، والأراضي البعيدة فيها كلفة إضافية
حق النقل وحق الشحن الداخلي
كيف تقييمك لأسعار الأراضي المحيطة بالموانئ؟
أعتقد إذا بندخل في مقارنة الأسعار
يمكن نستغرق عشرة دقائق نشرح التكلفة كاملة
لأن ليست فقط على سعر المتر
بس هذه نقطة أعتقد الكثير مهتم يفهمها
رقم واحد، احنا إلى حديث أخوي «خالد»
ما كان فيه مناطق حرة أصلًا، وهذا فارق كبير
بمعزل عن سعر المتر
كل العمليات التي تقوم في المنطقة الحرة
لازم تكون في المنطقة الحرة
بغض النظر، إن شاء الله أخذت المتر ببلاش
فالمقارنة بشيء موجود بشيء وبشي مو موجود
أول شيء لازم نُنشئ المنطقة الحرة، بعدين نشوف سعر...
اليوم المناطق الحرة اللي أنشأتوها هل بديتوا بالأسعار هذه؟
لا أرخص بكثير
كم بديتوا؟
فيه ناس اللي في منطقة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية
عندهم خمس سنوات إعفاء مثلًا من أي إيجار
الين ما يبني المستودع، حسب حجم المستودع
لكن الإيجارات فيها عشرين أو ثلاثين ريال، مو مرتفعة
أنا عضو مجلس إدارة في المنطقة الحرة
اللي تعمل الآن في المملكة اللي هي بجوار مطار الرياض
الطلب عالي جدًّا، مع ذلك محافظين على سعر المتر أربعين ريال
إذا تاخذ أرض في الرياض في «السلي»
ماهي جنب المطار، ماهي أساسية، وماهي منطقة حرة
100-150 ريال المتر
لكن في المنطقة الحرة؛ حافظنا على أربعين ريال متر
باشتراط على الشركة اللي تجي
لازم وزن معين يضمنوه لنا بالحركة
لأن هدفنا اقتصادي أكبر من هدف العائد المباشر
فأولًا لازم تنشئ المنطقة الحرة
وبعدين يكون فيها السعر الأميز
فيما دون ذلك؛ عرض وطلب
أكيد إذا ما فيه طلب...
احنا في المراكز اللوجستية بيكون فيه مناطق كبيرة
بالتالي نتوقع عشان العرض والطلب؛ تبدأ تنخفض الأسعار
يعرف كل الإخوان أني ماني مع سياسة التدخل الكثير في الأسعار
أنا أتدخل أن أوفّر الخدمة متكاملة
لكن أيش فائدة تخلي المتر سبعة ريال
ومعتمد على الدعم الحكومي
اليوم فيه سيولة زايدة بننشئه
بكرة فيه أولوية أخرى؛ تتوقف المشاريع
هذا ماهو مستدام
وأنا ودي القطاع الخاص هو اللي يدخل
ويطور المراكز اللوجستية مو بالحكومة
فلازم يكون على المطور العقاري أيضًا فيه عائد
لكن مع كسر أي نوع من النوع الاحتكار
وتوفير مساحات جيدة؛ طبيعي أن الأسعار راح تتحسن
هذا أبرز ما صار في موضوع الموانئ
وعندنا حلقة كاملة على هذا القطاع
فخلينا نروح للسكك مثلًا
السكك إن شاء الله بتكون قصة نجاح رائعة جدًّا
سكة الحديد اليوم أصلًا ما في مسار فاضي
ما في قطار يمشي فاضي، لا ركاب
ويا ما كلمت رئيس «سار» الله يذكره بالخير
أبغى تذكرة
ما شاء الله تبغى تروح أي مكان
قطار «الحرمين» دائمًا -ما شاء الله- فيه طلب متزايد
معقولة؟!
إيه
تجربتي مختلفة أنا
أنا قطار «الحرمين» مرتين ركبته كان فاضي تمامًا
كنت لحالي حرفيًا
ما أعرف أنت، سبحان الله في المرتين اضطريت أكلمه
وهنا كنت أتابع كرة كثير
فأحيانًا يكون فيه مباريات في «المجمعة»
ما ألاقي حجوزات في الإجازة الأسبوعية وأروح أشوف
فيه طبعًا قطار البضائع اللي بين الدمام والرياض أيضًا مليان
وحتى دائمًا نكلمهم أنه خفّضوها أقل من البر
عشان يصير التصدير عبر الميناء الجاف أكثر
ما في ولا عربة فاضية
فهي فيه قصة نجاح كبيرة بتكون للقطارات
فيه مشروع كبير وكبير جدًّا في القطارات
اللي هو الجسر البري
كلنا في المنظومة قريبين منه
لأنه يربط «ينبع» بميناء الملك عبدالله وميناء جدة الإسلامي
داخل المحطات
بالرياض، «الدمام» «الجبيل» «رأس الخير»
خمس موانئ، ثلاث مطارات، وأربعة عشر مركز لوجستي
بين موانئ جافة وبين مناطق إيداع مرتبطة...
أنا بالنسبة لي هذا «الكوريدور»
اللي يربط الخمسة موانئ، أربعة عشر مركز لوجستي
منها سبعة موانئ جافة، وثلاث مطارات
راح يكون عصب اللوجستي الأساسي في المملكة العربية السعودية
طيب سولف لنا عنه أكثر؟
لأن هذا ما شاء الله موجود في كل حلقة نصورها
نسمع عنه ولا نشوفه
بقول لك حصرية
هو التصاميم منتهية، واستغراق الزمن لبناءه
من سبعة إلى عشرة سنوات بشكل مكتمل
طبعًا هي المحطات راح تخلص أول
بالذات اللي هي الرياض-الرياض
اللي هي من جنوب الرياض لشمال الرياض
هذا من أول المراحل اللي فيه
هو طبعًا يبنى عن طريق تحالف صيني
وفيه مسارين للتمويل
وهذا اللي أقول لك، فيه كثير من المواقف
يمكن اليوم راح نذكر كم واحد منها
بس فيه كثير من المواقف يدلك حرص القيادة على القطاع؛ محرج
حتى مؤخرًا كان فيه اجتماع بحضور سمو سيدي
وكنا نتكلم على تأخر بعض التمويل
فأول ما بدأ قال: أنا أعتذر منكم
يحرجك بالاهتمام الكبير بهذا القطاع
فالشاهد أن الحكومة الصينية عارضة التمويل باشتراطات معينة
فيها كثير من مصالح الشركات الصينية طبيعي وغير ذلك
واحنا عندنا دائمًا مستهدفات
أن فيه نسبة المحتوى المحلي والتشغيل السعودي أعلى
فلما المفاوضات أخذت وقت
خلقنا مسار آخر للتمويل الداخلي
وانتهى ووافقت عليه كل الجهات ذات الاختصاص
والآن إذا ما قفلنا اتفاق التمويل
أما اتفاق التصاميم منتهي خلاص
إذا ما قفلنا اتفاق التمويل مع الدولة الأخرى
المسار الثاني بينطلق مباشرة
كم تكلفة الجسر البري؟
رأس مالية فوق الـ 100 مليار أو 120 مليار
ريال؟
ريال
وتعرف هذه المشاريع العوائد المباشرة منها ما تغطي تكاليفها
هي العوائد الاقتصادية
فأيضًا إذا حسبنا التكلفة التشغيلية
من الحين إلى 2047
الآن نتكلم على فوق الـ 240 مليار، فهو تكلفة
هذه 240 مليار عوائد التشغيل وللا إيه؟
لا، هذه تكلفة التشغيل زائد تكلفة التشغيل
يعني التأسيس، ولكن يكون دائمًا تكلفة تشغيله
أكثر من عوائده المباشرة
وهذا مثلًا مثال أنا أعطيك
في المفاوضات إذا أعطيتهم سكة الحديد
هم ودهم يأخذون كمان المراكز اللوجستية اللي جنبها
عشان يصير العائد مُجدي من سلبي إلى إيجابي
الإيجابي من 2% «آي آر آر» مو بـ 7% أو 8%
لكن يكون من ناقص 3% أو 4%
إذا دمجت المراكز اللوجستية فقط
سيبك من الأثر الاقتصادي للصناعة والزراعة والمستهلك وغير كذا
بس المراكز هذه الأربعة عشر
إذا دمجتها في المشروع؛ تصير العوائد إيجابية
فهو دائمًا الأثر يتجاوز فقط سكة الحديد
وعشان أفهمه أكثر، الجزء اللي بينفذ هو من الرياض إلى جدة، صح؟
نعم
لأن الأجزاء الأخرى موجودة، أو صحح لي
أول شيء بيكون فيه ركاب، سريع مثل «الحرمين»
بين الرياض والدمام
كل الاتصال بيكون فيه قطار سريع
باستثناء جدة-الرياض؛ هذه بتكون فقط بضائع
اللي هو مختلف تقنية سكك الحديد اللي فيها
ولكن البضائع لا
«ينبع» إلى جدة والرياض؛ كلها بضائع
بس سكة جديدة
حتى الرياض إلى الدمام سكة جديدة؟
بيتم تطوير السكة الحالية، لأنها تقنية شوي مختلفة عن الحالي
فالجزء اللي بيُبنى من الرياض إلى جدة ومن جدة إلى «ينبع»
هذا الجزء الجديد اللي بيُبنى من الصفر
إيه، إلى جنوب جدة ومن جنوب جدة
إلى داخل كل محطة في الميناء، هذا أهم شيء
أنت لازم تخلي التجربة كاملة
حتى إلى ميناء الملك عبدالله راح يدخل إلى داخل الميناء
والآن ما يدخل داخل الميناء
أنا كلوجيستي يصير عندي خيارات كثير
صح
أنا في الرياض أبغى مصنعي
أقدر أرسله لأي ميناء شرق أو غرب أو أي مطار بشكل...
كلها مربوطة بشبكة واحدة من السكك
إيه
ممتاز، الشبكة هذه يفترض أن فيها مراكز لوجستية
نعم
هذه بنسولف عنها بعدين لما نتكلم عن المراكز
وللا ممكن نسولف عنها الحين؟
ممكن نسولف عنها الحين، لكن هو هذا الهدف
المراكز اللوجستية تسمى متعددة الوسائط
اللي هي بين أسلوب وأسلوب ثاني
مداخل الرياض فيه ازدحام شديد
صح
ودائمًا الشاحنات تكون واقفة برّا
الهدف أن تجي الشاحنات بسرعة
على المراكز اللوجستية في أطراف الرياض تنزل بضاعتها
بعدين ديّانات وشاحنات تخرج من هذه المراكز
توزع داخل الرياض وهكذا
فيه مراكز لوجستية بجوار المطار
نفس الشيء ودك الأشياء اللي تجي ما تتأخر
تروح على المستودعات اللي هناك
من الطائرة إلى المستودعات
وبعدين الشاحنات والديّانات هي اللي تاخذها
ونفس الشيء على الموانئ
فهي دائمًا المراكز هي نقطة التقاء أكثر من وسيلة شحن
أو وسيلة واحدة بريًّا بس مثلًا تدخل ضخمة وتخرج صغيرة
هذا دورها الأكبر
ولما نتكلم عن مراحل تنفيذ من سبع إلى عشر سنوات
الجسر البري نعم
الجسر البري
أول جزء أنت قلت من الرياض للرياض
اشرح لنا عنه أكثر تكفى
طبعًا هو بيكون فيه ميناء جاف جديد جنوب الرياض كبير
جزء من المخطط الرئيسي بمدينة الرياض
فالخط اللي يجي من الشرقية بيدخل الجنوب
مثل ما هو حاليًا إلى الميناء الجديد
بعدين عندنا خط الشمال اللي عند المطار
وطالع إلى «سدير» وشمالًا إلى حدود الأردن
إذا وصلت أنت إلى حدود الأردن
تجد سكة الحديد تصل إلى الحدود وتقف
صح
يمكن عشرة كيلو الفارق
فهذا الاتصال ضروري
بيكون فيه اتصال من محطة جنوب الرياض
إلى محطة شمال الرياض
بالتالي البضاعة اللي تجي من أي منطقة في المنطقة الشرقية
ومن الجانب الآخر عندك الإمارات لاحقًّا والبحرين
والحين احنا نجي إلى هذا القسم
يصل إلى الرياض وبإمكانه مباشرةً
أن يستمر إلى شمال المملكة والدخول إلى الأردن
مثل المشروع اللي أُعلن قريبًا
أو التحول إلى البحر الأحمر والوصول إلى موانئ
أنا بقول لك كلوجيستي هذا المشروع بالنسبة لي
هو راح يكون نقطة تحوّل، راح يكون مختلف تمامًا
هذا حجر الزاوية لمشروعك اللوجيستي بالكامل
100%
وكان فيه أتذكر، على طاري الجزء السككي
ممكن يكون هذا مدخل لموضوع النقل البري
كان فيه حديث لأتوقع رئيس موانئ دبي
وكان يتكلم على أن مهما صار من حراك
في النقل البري أو السككي
الكلام كله على النقل البحري
فهذا الجهد كله لن يساوي شيء
مقارنةً بمعبر قناة «السويس» والنقل البحري
اللي هو الأساس في الشحن
إيه، إذا قلنا أنه أثر سلبي على النقل البحري؛ لا
ودحين أشرح ليش
لكن هل هناك قيمة كبيرة لهذا النقل البري السككي
سواءً سككي أو غيره؟
نعم هناك قيمة كبيرة
فتقريبًا 85% من حجم الشحن العالمي هو شحن بحري
ولما أعلن سمو سيدي عن الربط بين قوة اقتصادية كبيرة في أوربا
وقوة اقتصادية كبيرة وقاعدة تنمو بشكل سريع
اللي هي الهند مستقبل الاقتصاد
أوربا قاعدة تتقلص أو تتباطئ
والهند أحد الدول اللي قاعدة تتسارع فيه
صح
فربط هذه الدولتين بخط طاقة وبيانات وربط مباشر
راح يكون له قيمة كبيرة ما في شك في ذلك
وكثير من البضائع اللي هي قيمة عالية
ترى التكلفة اللوجستية تكاد لا تكون مهمة
يصير يهمهم أسرع وأكثر طريق مباشر
إلكترونيات، والرقائق الإلكترونية والجوالات والأدوية
مهم جدًّا يكون فيه سرعة ومباشرة في هذه الأمور
وعصب مهم في الحالات الحرجة والخطيرة
هنا يجي دور النقل السككي
هذا النقل السككي كم يشكل من حركة البضاعة بين الشرق والغرب؟
لن تتجاوز 2% - 3%
مو بس هذا الخط، كل الخطوط الأخرى
فيه ستة خطوط سككية بين الصين وأوربا
كل هذولي 2%
2% - 3% من الحجم
وحتى أنا أستغرب بعض الطرح
هو ما أستغربه، لكن أقول غير دقيق
لما يقولوا: هذا تهديد لقناة «السويس»
المملكة العربية السعودية عندها على البحر الأحمر «نيوم»
وميناء «أكتاقون» وعندها «ينبع» ومشاريع الكبيرة على (...)*
وعندها ميناء الملك عبدالله والمنطقة الحرة اللي فيه
وعندها ميناء جدة الإسلامي فيه ست مناطق لوجستية
تبع «إم إس سي» و«ميرس كلاين» وغيرها أُعلنت عنه
وتوسعة لشركة موانئ البحر الأحمر، وعندنا «جيزان»
بالنسبة لنا البحر الأحمر هو عصب مهم وعصب أساسي
وعندنا استثمارات من القطاع الخاص كبيرة
في المناطق الحرة بجيبوتي وفي «العين السخنة» في مصر
فما في شك البحر الأحمر قناة نقل كبيرة ومهمة ورائعة
وما في شك فيه جدوى كبيرة
يمكن يعطيك مثال عمر بيشرح
كذا دخلنا شوي على الشحن الجوي
حجم البضائع اللي تجينا عبر الإمارات
بعدين تجينا بالبر
بالنسبة لحجم واردات المملكة كلها كوزن 1.7%
أنا معلومتي أقدر أؤكد أنها أكثر دقة
اللي تجي الإمارات بعدين تدخل علينا
بالشاحنات
بر
ويكون بلد المنشأ اللي فيها ما زالت الدولة الأساسية الصين
ما تغيّر بلد المنشأة إلى منطقة حرة
هذا الـ 1.7% كم تشكل كقيمة؟
8% من حجم الواردات في المملكة
أوف!
وزن 1.5% كقيمة 8% ليش هذا التباين الكبير؟
لأن معظمها إلكترونيات وتجارة الإلكترونية وغيرها
معظمها تجي طيران على الإمارات تدخل عبر المنفذ وهو البحرين
تروح إلى مطار الملك فهد بالدمام
ويتم فسحها هناك
كقيمة مهم، كوزن محدودة
إذا جينا إلى اللي يروح للإمارات، لكن يجينا عن طريق البحر
كوزن تقريبًا 12%
كقيمة؟
كقيمة أيضًا 7%
فهنا تشوف الفارق
اثنينهم مهم، كل واحد له دور مؤثر وحساس
في سلاسل الإمداد العالمي، لكن أنت عاد تحسبها
فهل هناك خطورة على قناة «السويس»
وللا على البحر الأحمر وللا على مشاريعنا إلى هناك؟ لا
هل هناك قيمة كبيرة لهذه سكك الحديد؟
لا شك في ذلك
ولما جاء الحديث على موضوع الممر الاقتصادي
كان ملفت للنظر أنه يبدأ من الإمارات
فهنا يجي سؤال، إذا نتكلم على سرعة وسهولة الوصول من الهند
عُمان كميناء مهيئة أكثر
إذا نتكلم على الموانئ اللي في الخليج
إذا السفينة دخلت مضيق «هرمز» وخذت المشوار الإضافي هذا كله
ليش توقف في دبي ورى ما توقف في الدمام مباشرةً
ونختصر احنا محطة كاملة موجودة في الممر الاقتصادي؟
أيش سبب أن البداية من الإمارات
إيه، أنا ما أعرف السبب لهذه الحالة بالتحديد
بس أقدر أخمن عدد من الأسباب اللي تؤدي إلى ذلك
لما قارننا تكلفة الواردات للدول كلها
من الشرق إلى موانئ الإماراتية بالتحديد ميناء «جبل علي»
تكلفة الشحن البحري تقريبًا نصف تكلفة الشحن البحري
لميناء الملك عبدالعزيز وهم جنب بعض
لأن هناك صادرات كبيرة تطلع من ميناء «جبل علي»
وبالتالي تكلفة الشحن البحري تنقسم على اثنين
هناك لا
لما قارناها في جدة، جدة أسعارها مقاربة
وفي بعض الدول أرخص
فهذا أول قيمة
أنت عندك استثمارات هندية كبيرة جدًّا في المناطق الحرة
في الإمارات موجودة اليوم
فيه في المناطق الحرة 9000 شركة اليوم
عدد كبير منها من دولة الهند الشقيقة
فبالتالي من المنطق والسهل
عندي موظفين وعندي شركات وعندي مخازن
ليش أبدأ في مكان جديد وأسوي فيه الاتصال هذا؟
وإذا جاءت على اليوم الإضافي أو نصف اليوم ماهي بقضية
ماهي يوم، أقل بكثير
ساعات إضافية ماهي بقضية كبيرة
هذا تخمين من عندي
إذا أنا كنت محلهم كان هذا أقرب
هو يبدأ من دبي وبعدين يدخل على السعودية بري
هنا بيصير فيه سكك؟
إيه، هنا -سبحان الله- كان دائمًا الكلام في السابق
وأعتقد ممتاز جدًّا لو تستضيف لاحقًّا
اللي هو الدكتور «بشار» أو رئيس «سار»
يمكن عندهم تفاصيل أفضل من اللي عندي
أنا أقول اللي أنا أعرفه
كان دائمًا في السابق الحديث
أن الجسر البري أول مشروعنا «الكوريدور»
«فيز 2» بيكون الربط مع دول الخليج
عُمان، الإمارات، الكويت، البحرين
و«فيز 3» الربط الشمالي
فيه رغبة من كل الدول، حتى والله لما كنت أنا...
أنا ما لي علاقة بسكك الحديد بشكل مباشر
بس أي دولة أزورها
بتبدأوا الربط الخليجي؟ ودنا نساهم في الربط الخليجي
دول أوربية، دول أمريكية، دول شرق آسيا
يعني العالم ترى
ليش؟
مشاريع كبرى هذه وفيها فرص استثمارية
لشركات إسبانية وشركات صينية
فالكل وده يكون جزء
ففيه رغبة في ذلك، وفيه حاجة لذلك
ففجأة بعدما كانت هذه «فيز 2» وهذه «فيز 1»
صاروا في نفس الوقت
أنا أعتقد حسب الأرقام اللي أشوفها
بعض الربط الخليجي بيخلص قبل الجسر البري
هل بدأ الربط الخليجي؟
هو شُكّل مجلس الربط الخليجي
حُدد المسار؟
حددت المسارات
فيه بعض الدول وصلوا للمنفذ
خلاص هم جاهزين من طرفهم
كسكة خلصوها؟
نعم، الإمارات جاهزة من أبوظبي إلى...
فهم مستبقين الربط
فنتوقع أن الربط الخليجي
الإمارات تحديدًا عشان هذا المسار
لكن الدول الأخرى، شفت أنت الإعلان قبل أسبوعين
في مجلس الوزراء على الربط مع الكويت
صحيح
وطبعًا من الكويت إلى العراق
ومن العراق تقدر تربط بالـ«سيلكرود»
الـ«السيلكرود» اللي هو الصيني التركي الأوربي
وهذه النظرة أنا في نظري صحيحة
هي ماهي هذا راح يضر هذا
احنا كل هذه الاقتصادات بعيدة عن حجمها الحقيقي
بالنسبة للموارد اللي فيها والقدرات؛ كلها بعيدة جدًّا
متى ما شكّلت أكثر من مجال للتصدير والاستيراد
كل هذه الاقتصادات تنجح
فهي ماهي أنا عندي كيكة وين تروح!
أكبر مثال من أزحم خطوط طيران اليوم: دبي-الرياض
هذا التنافس بين الإمارات والمملكة في كل المجالات مين استفاد منه؟
الإمارات والسعودية
من أزحم الخطوط في العالم، دائمًا في أعلى خمسة
خط دبي-الرياض، والبضائع كذلك
وتخيل دبي-الرياض، ونيودلهي-الرياض
وبغداد-الرياض، وصنعاء-الرياض
هذا هو، فلذلك احنا ما ننظر...
مشروع الربط الخليجي، مين المسؤول عنه؟
هناك الجسر البري قلنا تحالف صيني
تكلفة 100 مليار وسبعة إلى عشرة سنوات
هنا عندنا معلومات واضحة؟
إيه، قد لا تتجاوز ثلاث سنوات بعد الربط
هناك مجلس ترأسه المملكة العربية السعودية في كل دول الخليج
مجلس الربط السككي الخليجي هم اللي عندهم
كل دولة مسؤولة عن تنفيذ الجزء اللي في أراضيها
فيه تفاصيل، بس كل دولة راح تشارك
والجزء اللي يخص السعودية، متى متوقع انتهاءه؟
كل دولة لها، أسرع وحدة بتكون الإمارات
ما حددوا البقية
أسرع دولة غالبًا بتكون الإمارات، اللي توقع خلال ثلاث سنوات
والجسر البري يمر بإحدى الدول الخليجية وللا ما له علاقة؟
إيه مو هو بيرتبط، وهذه الميزة
احنا الجسر البري يصل إلى الدمام
وربط الدول الخليجية كله يصل إلى الدمام
أنا قلت لك الجسر البري يصل إلى «رأس الخير»
امتداده هو الكويت، ومنه بيخرج للبحرين
ومنه راح ينزل الجنوب إلى قطر وإلى الإمارات ومن الإمارات إلى عُمان
كل هذا عشان ربط الممر الاقتصادي وغيرها
ترى لما يوصل الرياض
من الرياض؛ جنوب الرياض فيه مشروع كبير صناعي لوجستي
ضخم جدًّا بحجم «القدّية» يمكن
هذا المركز بيكون عنده ربط بكل دول الخليج بالشمال إلى أوربا
بيكون فيه مركز كبير لذلك
هذا بالنسبة للقطاع السككي
طيب الشحن الجوي؟
أيش أبرز ما تحقق الفترة الماضية؟
وأيش عندنا في الفترة الجاية؟
خلينا ناخذ خطوة كذا، التوجه في الدولة من ضمن الرؤية
هو أن كل الشركات أول شيء تنتقل
من المنظومة الحكومية إلى منظومة القطاع الخاص
«بي آي إف» أو صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
هو رافعة كبيرة لتفعيل ذلك
بالذات مشاريع ذات العوائد المجزية
اللي تحقق عوائد مقبولة للصندوق
ويصير دور الدولة تتقلص الجهات الحكومية
ودورها تشريعي بحت
والتشريعي له قسمين: قسم تشريع فني
والله وزن الحاوية ما يتجاوز
نبغى أربع كفرات في الشاحنة
وفيه منها قسم اقتصادي
وهذا كل الجهات الحكومية قاعدة تبني خبرة فيه أكبر ما كانت موجودة
أعطيتك مثال كيف الموانئ لما غيّروا التشريعات الاقتصادية
كيف كان الأثر الكبير
في المطارات تغيّرت أول نوع من التشريعات
لأن كان فيه سعر عالي لمطارات المملكة
تكلفة عالية؛ فتنافسيتها ضعيفة
فصار التركيز في المطار التكاليف المرتبطة
بهبوط الطائرة وإقلاعها وغيرها
صار فيه حوكمة كبيرة
تبا تدخل الفلوس؛ دخّلها من المطاعم، دخّلها من الأسواق الحرة
دخّلها من الخدمات الإضافية
لكن الخدمات الأساسية لازم تكون...
وهذا تم قبل سنة ونص وبدأت النتائج
فأسعار الخدمات الأرضية هذه بشكل عام؛ انخفضت
أسعار الهبوط والإقلاع والخدمات الأرضية
انخفضت الآن خلال سنة ونص الماضية
لكن هذا ما يكفي، هذه كانت الحزمة الأولى
الحزمة الثانية الآن أُعتمدت في مجلس الإدارة
أو في مصيرها للاعتماد
هذه معقدة جدًّا
اللي هي كل شركة مشغلة أيش الأداء المطلوب منها؟
أنت شركة الباصات، إذا أكثر من كذا عليك عقوبة
ولازم يكون رضا المستفيد ما يقل عن كذا
لازم انتظار الطائرة ما يزيد عن كذا
وكل مرة الطائرة تستنى أكثر من خمسة عشر دقيقة
عليك يا مشغّل عقوبة
أول حزمة كانت أنك ما ترفع سعرك فوق رقم معين
الآن لا، مردودك المالي يعتمد على أدائك
طبعًا هذا ياخذ وقت التتبع
ياخذ وقت إلى أن العقود بين المطارات
والشركات المشغلة تتغيّر، لأن فيها موظفين
لكن هذا لما يبدأ يُفعّل
راح يصير تمامًا مثل ما صار في الموانئ
خل نفترض أني في موقف رئيس الخدمات الأرضية
لما أروح لمجلس إدارتي الآن
ترى العقد تغيّر يا أخوان
أنا أحتاج موظفين هنا إضافين، أحتاج هنا كذا
تتغيّر لغة التعامل حتى بين الرؤساء التنفيذيين
وأشوف هذه برضه تنعكس على حركة الشحن
هذه راح تغيّرها بشكل كبير
احنا في المطارات نحتاج...
إذن التشريعات الأساسية تمت
التشريعات الاقتصادية المرحلة الثانية الآن أُعلنت
البنية التحتية ما زال فيها عمل في المطارين الرئيسيين
الرياض-جدة
تأخرنا لأن كان فيه مخطط رئيسي جديد لكلا المطارين جدة والرياض
وأُعتمد المخطط الرئيسي للمطارين من ستة أشهر تقريبًا
مطار جدة الممتاز أن منطقة الشحن
هي نفسها المنطقة الحالية توسعة لها
فكان عندها ست أو سبع شركات
كانت متوقفة وما تقدر تبني مستودعاتها
الآن كلها تبني مستودعاتها
فهذا راح يرفع من أداء جدة بشكل كبير
في الرياض لا، منطقة المستودعات في المخطط العام الجديد
مختلفة عن منطقة المستودعات الحالية
بالتالي على المدى البعيد؛ فيه طمأنينة أنه عارفين أيش بيصير
على المدى القريب؛ عندنا عدد من الشركات جاهزة تبني
ومن غير ما تبني، مهما حسّننا من خدماتنا
أنت لازم تحل كل شيء
لازم تحل الإجراءات التشريعية والإجراءات الاقتصادية والبنية التحتية
فقاعدين الآن الإخوان في الهيئة العامة للطيران
مع صندوق استثمارات العامة
لأن المطارات كلها راح تنتقل لهم
ومع منظومة النقل ووزارة النقل
يعملون على خطة على المدى القريب
لحل هذا الإشكال إلى أن يكون الخطة...
هذه المناطق هي اللي سمعنا قبل فترة أبل أخذت موقع فيها؟
هي نفسها وللا غيرها؟
أبل في المنطقة الحرة
في المنطقة الحرة، أجل المناطق هذه أيش هي؟
مناطق الشحن؟
إيه هذه هي
أنا الآن في الرياض بالذات
ما شاء الله استيراد «الكافيار» كل يوم وشرائح اللحم الطازجة
والأشياء الطازجة
وهذه المطاعم يعانون معناة كبيرة
ومهما حليت إجراءات وقوانين
من غير مستودعات متخصصة وأدوات متخصصة؛ ما راح تقدر
ليش هذول المستودعات ما جات؟
لأن كان فيه إيقاف لكل المستودعات في المطار
الين انتهاء المخطط العام
ولما انتهى المخطط العام طلع الموقع مختلف
ولسه مو بجاهز
هذاك يجهز في 2027-2028
أوه!
فالآن فيه فريق مشكّل لحل الفجوة
فهذه ما زالت تحدي قائم
وأيضًا فتح السوق
طبعًا السعودية للشحن الطائرات مثل ما قلت لك تجي
اللي هي «سال»؟
لا، السعودية للشحن
تجي مليانة اليوم
وفيه جزء من السوق ما راح تقدر بوضعك الحالي تجيبه
هذا يجي معظمه للإمارات
اللي قلت لك 1.7% من الوزن، لكن 8% أو 7.5% من القيمة
هذا ماهو بسهل تجيبه، ليش؟
معظم الشركات ووسطاء الشحن وغيرها
تتعامل مع طيران الإمارات أو ما حوله
أنها تجيبها لمركز التوزيع هناك
وبعدين عندهم ممكن نشاط المسافر لكل دول العالم
سريعة ويومية ورحلات مباشرة
فهو ما يقدر، حتى لو معظم البضاعة تجي السعودية
هذا السوق ترى كذا عمله
إذا قلت لشركة «إكس» ترى معظم مبيعاتكم في السعودية
جيبوها بشكل مباشر
يقول: إيه، بس أنا عندي كمان جزء من المبيعات ما يجي بشكل مباشر
إذا خسرت عقدي مع الإماراتية لـ 70% من عملي يبقى 30%
يرفعوا قيمة 30% كأنها 70% عرض وطلب
فهذه ما راح ننجح فيها الين يصير الخطوط نفسها ناجحة
في الربط مع دول العالم وعندها حجم أسطول
وعندها حجم وجهات كثيرة
مهما زودنا أسطول الخطوط السعودية للشحن
فيه جزء من السوق ما تقدر أنت تبدأ تنافس فيه
من غير ما بطن طائرات الركاب يكون موجود
بس احنا اليوم طلبنا 150 أو أكثر
طائرات ذات البدن العريض لخطوط طيران الرياض
وفيه خطوط السعودية تقريبًا خمسين
وفيه تقريبًا خمسين طائرة بدن ضيق، برضه مفيدة
فما عندي تخوّف
واستهدافات السياحة توّهم رفعوها
من 100 مليون إلى 150
هذا معناها بيجي طائرات إضافية
هذا إذا جاء؛ يمكننا نتغلغل في السوق الآخر
فلسى احنا نعتبر مرة ضعيفين في الشحن الجوي
فيه خطة، ما عندي خوف كبير على 2027 وطالع
بس من الحين إلى 2027
أيش سووا هيئة الطيران؟
بس هو الحلقة الأضعف حاليًا مقارنةً بالسككي والبحري
نعم، والمشكلة أن حلها ياخذ وقت حتى لو قررت
أنت لازم بناء مستودعات، لازم تشتري طيارات
ماهو قرار سهل الاتخاذ
لكن أيش سووا اليوم؟
الهيئة العامة للطيران أعطت الآن أربع شركات طيران
صلاحية أنهم يجيبوا شحن مباشر
ما صاروا يعتمدون على فقط الخطوط السعودية للشحن
فبدأ فتح السوق، نشر المنافسة بشكل أكبر
«لوكسمبورق» أخذت سبعة وعشرين رحلة محل ما يبون
الطائرات الصينية، الطائرات التركية
هذا أمر حسن للمستخدم
في الأخير مصلحة البلد هي الأولى
ووجود عدد كبير من المتنافسين أعتقد أن فيه مصلحة كبيرة
بس أنا أذكر قصة على هذا الموضوع
كنا نجتمع الظاهر مع معالي دكتور «ماجد القصبي» وزير التجارة
هو له علاقة بالتنافسية والتجارة الإلكترونية
فكان بنعرض عليه الحمد لله أرقام
كل شيء تزيد 20% - 30% سنة عن سنة، مو 5% أو 6%
فكنا نستعرض أن الشحن السريع أو الفسح السريع
في منفذ مطار جدة ومطار الرياض
قاعد يزيد 40% سنة عن سنة
مع كل القيود اللي قلت لك عليها
وشاف مطار الدمام نقص 20%
قال: روح للدمام وشوف أيش المشكلة؟
قلت: لا طال عمرك، هذا اللي يجي عن طريق البحرين والإمارات
يفسح في مطار الدمام
فيبان كأن هو نقص الشحن الجوي على الدمام
لكن هذا معناه أنه قاعد ينزل
كانت في القمة* حقها تصل 700 ألف
اللي كانت تجينا من دول الجوار، صارت تجينا بشكل مباشر
كانت 700 ألف الآن نزلت إلى 500 أو 450 اللي يجي إلى مطار
فأنت تشوفه مؤشر إيجابي؟
إيه
فصارت البضاعة تجي مباشرة
إيه، فقلت له: هذا دليل أنه...
قال: بس تأكد أن ما يكون خسرنا أي شيء من الشحن الجوي المباشر
وهذا متأكدين منه
فلذلك أنا أقول لك الطيران على المدى المتوسط 2027 وطالع
أعتقد فيه قصة نجاح بتكون كبيرة
آخرهم النقل البري، أيش أبرز ما تحقق فيه؟
النقل البري هو أصلًا كان الأعلى
هو اللي يشمل الشاحنات وكذلك الميل الأخير، صح؟
الميل الأخير يبغى لها فقرة لوحدها
طيب عطنا النقل البري الحين، وبعدين نشوف
أنا عندي ويعرفون مجلس الشراكة اللوجستي اللي أجلس معهم دائمًا
قلت لك: أنا ضد مبدأ خفّض خفّض أسعار
المتر بسبعة ريال
صحيح نبغى نزيد التنافسية
ولكن قلت لك وجهة نظري هذا الموضوع
اللوجستي دائمًا عنده رغبة أن ما في أي مركبة تمشي فاضية
ما أبغى طيارة تطلع فاضية، ما أبغى حاوية تمشي فاضية
وفي نفس الوقت ما أبغى شاحنة تمشي فاضية
فإذا فعلًا تبغى تخفّض سعر النقل البري
الحل مو أنك تسمح للشاحنات القديمة
ولا أنك تتساهل في المخالفات
وتخليهم يجيبوا سائقين، تستر
هذا مو الحل الصحيح
الحل أنك تضمن أن ما يقعد السائق اثنا عشر ساعة
عند مدخل الرياض يستنى دخوله
هذا نص يوم راح عليه
أعطيك قصص قصيرة توصل هذا الفكرة
أنا كان عندي زمان شركة توصّل طلبات الميل الأخير
شاحنات لـ«كارفور» و«بندة» وغيرها
ما كنا ندخل ربح كافي
إنما الأرباح 6% أو 4% أو 3% مع تعب شديد
خلينا على كل شاحنة ثلاث سائقين
الشاحنة ما توقف
الصباح تخدم «بندة» وفي العصر تخدم وفي المساء
كل واحدة فيها نوع من العميل مختلف
وصار أقدر أعطي أسعار مخفضة وأرباحي صارت زينة
فهذه كانت الفكرة
في المملكة العربية السعودية عمر
أفضل الشركات اللوجستية وأقواها؛ ماهي شركات لوجستية
كيف؟
«مراعي» أقوى شركة لوجستية في المملكة
هذه أقولها وأنا وكيل الخدمات اللوجستية
«نادك»
«مراعي» يقدر يوصل أي سوبرماركت في المملكة
أي بقالة في أنحاء المملكة في 24 ساعة، على الأكثر 48 ساعة
ما في أحد، لا «فيدكس» ولا كلهم
ما أحد عنده هذه القدرة
نسبة الاستعانة بمصادر خارجية
أو أنك تعطي الشغل لشركة خدمات لوجستية
في النقل البري بالتحديد
في المملكة 13% كانت قبل سنتين
يعني قليل ترى، المعدل العالي 30-40%
بمعنى كل واحد يقعد يسوي الشغل بنفسه
إيه، لأن ما كان فيه شركات قوية تقدر
وأنا أول ما جيت الوزارة كلمت معالي الوزير
وكلمت معايا الدكتور «ماجد القصبي» قلت لهم
خل نحاول نقنع الشركات هذه
عندها مستودعات وعندها شاحنات
طيب «المراعي» تروح مليانة، الشاحنة راجعة فاضية
خل نحط فيها منتج آخر
وجلست وقالوا: إذا رضيوا ما عندنا مشكلة
جلست معهم كلهم؛ «المراعي» تحفظّوا
حاولت معهم ويمكن مع الزمن يتغيّروا
لكن تحفّظوا وقالوا: احنا مبيعات يوم واحد نخسرها
أكبر بكثير عندنا من أي فائدة مرجوة من أننا ندخّل دخل إضافي
لكن «نادك» سوّوا شركة لوجستية وبدأت الآن
هي الشركة جاهزة، الشاحنات موجودة والمستودعات موجودة
نصيحتي كانت لهم أن يتشاركون مع شركات لوجستية
الـ «دي إن إيه» حقها خدمة
عشان لا يخرجون عن مجالهم اللي هم أقوياء فيه
«الدواء» أنشأت «بروسيد» وشوف الآن «بروسيد»
صارت تخدمهم وتخدم غيرهم
قبل ما أنا أجي، «إيكيا» سووا «فلو»
و«فلو» بدأت تكون قصة نجاح
بس أيش الاصلاح اللي سويتوه في القطاع
سواءً كجودة، كسرعة، كانتشار
أيش سويتوا حتى يكون القطاع هذا أكثر نجاحًا؟
إيه، صراحة الرؤية هي الأساس
المشاريع الضخمة في «القدّية» وفي «أمالة» والبحر الأحمر
والمواسم؛ ما زادت فقط الطلب على الحاجة اللوجستية
بل حتى النوعية
سيارات، لوح فنية
أشياء ما كان عندنا الحاجة إلى...
فحجم مشاركتنا من الناتج المحلي زادت 20%
في السنة الماضية بس
فحجم السوق ارتفع
والطلب على مستودعات محترفة وعلى شاحنات محترفة
وليس التوزيع التقليدي لمؤسسات فردية ضعيفة؛ ارتفع
احنا دورنا كان جزء منه كبير تسويق
عندنا عملاء يدوروا على مقدمين خدمة كويسين
وعندنا شركات كثير
أي شركة كبرى جاية؛ أوريها ست أو سبع شركات محلية
اتفقوا مع أي واحدة فيهم
واشجع «نادك» وأشجع «دواء» الله يذكرهم بالخير «بروسيد» وغيرها
أقول لهم شوفوا
أنت عارف واحد من أحسن شركات توصيل اليوم الميل الأخير
صار اسمها «دال» تابعة «إس تي سي»
أول كان توزيع شرائح
أنت لما تطلب شريحة «إس تي سي» توصلك في أقل من ساعة
صح
الآن صار يوصلون لـ«جرير»
فلو تشتري من «جرير» اليوم
ممكن توصلك في أقل من يوم، وجربتها
هي كفاءة ترفع
طالما أنا عندي الخدمة وعندي سيارات؛ هذه هي كانت
فالربط بين هذول وهذول، التحفيز
التراخيص عندنا صارت أسهل بكثير
الرخصة اللوجستية اللي فصّلها «خالد البواردي» الله يذكره بالخير
كان دائمًا في مجلس الشراكة يشتكي
كنت كل ما أسوي حركة؛ أرسلها لمجلس الشراكة
أقول لهم: يا إخوان، هذا هو اللي تبونه؟ وللا فيه تبغوا تعديل؟
الين ما أطلقناها مع بعض
اليوم أكثر من 1600 شركة أخذت الرخصة اللوجستية الموحدة
وطلباتها عبر الإنترنت تلقائي
ممكن الحين خلال هذه المقابلة
أكون طلّعت ثلاث أو أربع رخص عادي، ماهي صعب
فتسهيل الإجراءات، والتسويق اللي احنا نقوم فيه
تعريف السوق بهذا العمل أدى إلى ذلك
بعطيك مثال آخر، وأعتقد مثال ناس بيرتبطون فيه
«آيهرب» كانوا جايين لمملكة العربية السعودية
وتواصلوا مع وزارة التجارة ومع الدكتور «ماجد»
والدكتورة «إيمان» معالي نائب وزير التجارة
كلموني وقالوا: لازم تدعم تواجدهم وتشوف أيش يحتاجون
أخذتهم على مدينة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية
قلت لهم: الحين بيكون فيه منطقة حرة
بس احنا عارفين أنها جاية
وفيه جنب الرياض هذه المنطقة الحرة الثانية
قال لي المسؤول: احنا مبيعاتنا في المملكة العربية السعودية
أكثر من مبيعاتنا في أمريكا
واو!
70% من حجم المبيعات في المنطقة كلها في المملكة
و 70% من حجم مبيعاتنا في المملكة في الرياض
فأي شيء غير الرياض لا توريني
وهذا تكرر بشكل كبير
فشوف الحين التأثير
«آيهرب» يبون يسوون في المنطقة الحرة في  الرياض
بس هم يحتاجون شركة لوجستية
معظم الشركات الكبرى ما تسوي خدماتها اللوجستية بنفسها
فمين اللي هم يتعاملون معاه؟
شركة اسمها «سي جاي لوجستك» شركة كورية
لم يكن لها تواجد في المنطقة إلا ضعيف جدًّا
«سي جاي لوجستك» الآن موجودة في المملكة العربية السعودية
تبني المستودع في المنطقة الحرة
عشان تخدم «آيهرب» وغيرهم
«سي جاي» شركة كبيرة دخلها فوق المليار دولار
شركات كورية معظمها وغيرها
صار لها تواجد هنا، صار ممكن هي تسوّق لنا نجيب الشركات الكورية
طيب «سي جاي لوجستك» جات تبني مستوع
وهو مبني خصيصًا لذلك
تكلفته عالية
تشاركت مع شركة سعودية أن هي تبني المستودع
وتأجر لهم إياه خلال عشرين سنة
فأنت شوف الحركة الاقتصادية كيف
الشريك السعودي له دور، شركة وسيطة الشحن لها دور
والشركة العالمية لها دور
قصة مشابهة «شي إن»
طبعًا «شي إن» أنا وهم دائمًا في حوارات
كنت في الصين قريبًا
يبغون في المنطقة الحرة في الرياض 300 ألف متر مربع للمستودع
احنا المنطقة كلها 3 مليون متر مربع، وفيها وادي
طبعًا مع كود البناء في الرياض، نحافظ على الموارد
التضاريس الطبيعية
التضاريس الطبيعية، فراح جزء من الأرض
وبعدين فيه الطرق
فما بقي إلا أقل من مليونين متر مربع للتأجير
إذا بعت لشركة واحدة 300 ألف متر مربع
لكن قال لي: 68% من مبيعاته في الشرق الأوسط في الرياض
فمو بالمنطقي يكون في أي مكان ثاني
أول ما كان عندنا منطقة حرة في الرياض
شوف مهما حسّنت المنفذ من غير المنطقة الحرة ما ينتج
فيه معلومة جاتني، لأن طلبت منهم أشياء
حتى الفريق عندي يقول لي: أنت تكلمهم كأنهم موظفين عندك
أنا شديد
نبغاكم تسوقوا المنتج المحلي
نبغى اليوم الوطني السعودي يكون في مواقعكم كذا كذا
نبغاكم تربطوا بالعنوان الوطني المختصر
ترى احنا غير راضين عن هذا وهكذا
تعرف نحاول نقوم بدورنا
اللي يوصّل لـ«شي إن»
قال لي: سادس أكبر سوق في العالم لـ«شي إن»
هو المملكة العربية السعودية، وثاني أكبر سوق من حيث الربحية
إذا نظرت إلى الحد الأدنى؛ أنت ثاني أهم سوق بالنسبة لهم
فهذا يعطينا قدرة على التفاوض أكبر
احنا نأخذ هذه المعلومة ونستخدمها
فهذا اللي أنا أقولك، المنظومة كلها كذا
لازم تتكامل عشان تقدر تصل إلى النتيجة
وأنت شايف شكل السوق في المستقبل كنقل بري
أنه بتستمر كل شركة تنقل نفسها
ويصير عندنا أربع شاحنات في الشارع رايحين لنفس الوجهة؟
وللا تتخيل أن التطور الطبيعي
أنه بتبدأ هذه تندمج وتأسس شركات لوجستية عملاقة؟
اللي راح يصير الآتي: أول شيء عملنا مع وزارة البلدية
تعرف أنت اليوم عشان تطلّع ترخيص نقل؛ لازم يكون عندك أرض
وبتشتري أرض على شارع رئيسي
نص الناس تستأجر وتشتري في «ملهم»
أنا يوم كنت أشتغل، استأجرت أرض في «بقيق»
وطلعت الرخصة للنقل، وأنا عمري ما استخدمت هذه الأرض
لأن الشاحنة ما توقف عندي من عميل لعميل؛ فما فيه حاجة
اليوم مداخل الرياض في أربع مواقع
ومداخل جدة في أربع مواقع
ومداخل الدمام في موقعين
هي مواقف للشاحنات الكبيرة
اتفقنا مع الأمانة وهيئة تطوير المنطقة
ووزارة الشؤون البلدية والقروية
هذه تكون مواقف الشاحنات
أي واحد عنده عقد تأجير من مواقف الشاحنات هذه
مو بحاجة يكون عنده أرض عشان يطلع رخصة النقل
عشان نرفع من القيمة السوقية لهذه المراكز
أيضًا اتفقنا مع قسم الطرق في وزارة النقل
أن موازين الشاحنات أيضًا تكون في المواقع هذه
احنا نبغى المستثمرين يبنونها
راح تُطرح
المستثمر يبينها يكون عنده حركة مرور
وفيه حاجة للناس تجي له
لأن صار اللي يعمل عقد معاه
مو لازم يكون عنده أرض في «ملهم» وغيرها
فوفرنا بشكل كبير هناك
وأنا بالنسبة لي الشاحنات بدل ماهي واقفة
في الطريق السريع أربعة أو خمسة كيلو
تكون واقفة في مواقف مرتبة
وهناك يكون فيه مستودعات جنبها تاخذ هذا البضاعة وتدخل
هذا أكبر تغيير
أضف إلى ذلك مع مدينة الرياض
لازم يكون لها مدخل ما فيه توقّف
في المخطط الرئيسي للرياض اللي راح يعلن عنه
احنا منسقين معهم
راح يكون فيه مدخل إلى الرياض من الدمام
من جنوب الرياض ما فيه منع
الشاحنات اللي تجي تقدر تدخل على «سلي» وجنوب «سلي»
دون الحاجة أصلًا لدخول الرياض
ما ينطبق عليها موضوع ساعات دخول الشاحنات وإلى آخره
هذه ستخدم المدينة الصناعية اللوجستية
الصناعية اللوجستية اللي هي صراحة بتكون كبيرة
قلت لهم: مهما سوينا مواقف شاحنات وغيرها
ترى جنوب الرياض بهذا الحجم لا يحتمل التوقّف هذا
فوجدنا الآن حجم المساهمة في الناتج المحلي
ارتفع 20% في سنة وحدة
هذا نتيجة أن كثير من الشركات بدأت تعطي شغلها
إلى شركات تقديم الخدمات
أعتقد الشركات الصغيرة راح يكون لها دور
بالذات في المدن الصغيرة والنائية
أو الخدمات المتخصصة مثل اللوح وغيرها
والشركات الكبيرة راح تكون لها نصيب الأسد
بالذات مشاريع مثل «نيوم» والبحر الأحمر
الجسر البري عشان تبنيه تحتاج قدرة لوجستية كبيرة
لنقل كل هذا الحديد وغير ذلك
راح يكون لها دور
وما بين بين؛ فأعتقد كل الفئات لها دور في النهضة
وخلينا نختم هذه القطاعات
بقطاع يلامس الناس ويؤلمهم
وصدقًا ما أظن أن صار فيه تطور كبير في تجربة العميل
خلني أسألك متى أخر مرة طلبت؟
كل يوم
أيش رأيك في التجربة؟
كم مرة تكتب العنوان وترسله بالواتساب مشاركة الموقع
وتقول له: جنب المسجد الأبيض، عند الزبالة اللي مدري أيش
لو ما تعتبر إعلان غير مسموح في هذا العرض
أنا أقول: فيه ثلاث شركات اليوم، عمري ما حطيت لهم
أربع حروف وأربع أرقام وكلمني أحد بعدها
أنا ترى ما أستخدم إلا أربع حروف وأربعة أرقام
فقط؟
لي ستة شهور
قلها عادي بيستاهلون
الشركات: «ناقل إكسبرس» و«أرامكس» و«سبل»
هذولي الثلاثة أنت بس تحط لهم عنوانك الوطني
أي مرة عامل التوصيل يقول لي: موقعك
ما أرد إلا «آر آر إتش بي 3332» وهذا بيتي صار معروف الآن
عمرهم ما كلموني بعدها، يدق الجرس
البقية فيه تحسّن
لكن عشان تحسّن العنوان الوطني
عندك ثلاثة أو أربعة أشياء لازم تسويها
أول شيء لازم الناس تستخدمها أكثر
حتى في المواقع الإلكترونية
فالتوعية مهمة
مواقع التجارة الإلكترونية لازم...
عشان نكون شفافين
دائمًا رأيي نجبرهم بالذات المواقع السعودية
ما يسمح لك تدخل إلا أربعة حروف وأربعة أرقام
صحيح
لكن في رأيي أن في بعض المناطق «ديراب» وللا غيرها
يمكن ما فيه
فيه شركات صغيرة وللا فيه إنستقرام
فيه أراء مختلفة، طبعًا هذا غير...
ما فهمت؟ «ديراب» ما فيه عنوان؟ فيه عناوين
في بعض الأراضي في «ديراب» اليوم
مثلًا لسه العنوان الوطني الكامل
ما في إلا أربعة حروف وأربعة أرقام
ليش ما صار عندها؟
هي كتقنية عند البريد السعودي جاهز
بس لازم يتفقون مع الأمانات والبلديات الفرعية
على إطلاق هذه وبعدين يتفقون مع قوقل وغيرها على الإطلاق
فهي عملية ياخذونها بالأولوية
فالمدن الرئيسية كلها 20 مليون عنوان مختصر تم
بس احنا عندنا أكثر من 20 مليون
بالذات لو أنت خارج المدن الرئيسية
لكن هو كتقنية موجود
أي متر مربع × متر مربع
عندهم القدرة «سبل» يطلعون له أربعة حروف وأربعة أرقام
هذه تفصيلة بس أنا أقول لك
فلازم تُجبر
أنا كنت في الصين قبل شهر ونص
قابلت «شي إن» و «جي دي» و «علي إكسبرس»
وكان معي رئيسة العنوان الوطني
يعطيها الصحة والعافية، الأستاذة «عالية السبتي»
كلهم وقعوا معنا أن في موقعهم إذا بتشتري من السعودية
بيطلع لك خيار؛ لو حطيت أربعة حروف وأربعة أرقام
خلاص ما تحط ولا شيء ثاني، لكن مو إجبار
هو خيار موجود هم يربطون بالعنوان الوطني المحلي
إذا احنا غطينا ترى هي سبعة أو ثمانية مواقع
يعني غطينا 80-90%
«شي إن» وافقوا، وكانوا شوي في أخذ وجذب
لكن وافقوا ووقعوا اتفاقية الربط بالعنوان الوطني
فهذا على مستوى المتاجر
بعدين تبغى اللي هم تحتنا شركات التوصيل
اجتمعنا معهم كلهم
وميزتها أن ماهي كثير مرة الشركات السبعة أو الثمانية الكبار
يتحكمون في 80% من حركة السوق
فبعضهم صراحة قوي، وبعضهم...
حتى اللي ربط فنيًا، لكن موظفينه ما زال
واضح أن فيه فجوة
قشران احنا فهذا الوضوع معهم، احنا شديدين كنا مرة
حتى والله واحنا في الصين، الفريق عندي دائمًا يضحك
كنت أجلس مع رئيس شركة «آي مايل»
اللي هي الآن رقم واحد في التوصيل في المملكة
في المملكة؟
إيه
اسمها «آي مايل»
هذه أيش جنسيتها؟
هذه صينية
والحين ممكن نتطرق، من القصة الطريفة
كنت أسمّع السواقين حقنا واحد واحد
لأني أطلب دائمًا
أنا عندي البيت ما يوقف طلبات
فعليًّا كل يوم عندي طلبتين أو ثلاثة
فأسمّعهم
«آي مايل» وعدوا شهر وينتهي هذا تمامًا
أنا عاتبتهم على أشياء كثير
ما يصير أقولها في هذا
طبعًا هي «آي مايل» مملوكة لـ«شي إن»
فهو «سعيد» يعرف ستة عشر مستودع في المملكة
يقول: أنا رحت «جيزان» ورحت ما أعرف فين
قلت له: ممتاز ورائع، لكن أنت أخذت السوق
لأن عندك المصدر
ففيه تحديين مع هذا النوع من الشركات
لأن أسعارهم أحيانًا أقل من سعر التكلفة
وهذا حلينا جزء كبير منه وشغالين على الباقي
أنا يهمني تخفيض الأسعار، ولكن مو بالطريقة اللي...
تكافئ السوق ويطلّع الناس
رقم اثنين، قلت له: أنت لأن عندك الحصة السوقية
تحكمت بشكل كبير في السوق
كم موظف سعودي عندك؟
حتى لو أنت سعودة، أنت أيش دورك في التنمية؟
فكلا الشركتين الصينيتين اللي قابلتها
وقعوا مع الأكاديمية السعودية
وحدة 100 متدرب منتهية بالتوظيف
ووحدة 80 متدرب منتهية بالتوظيف
عدد كبير يعتبر
هم كمستودعات مو بهذا...
هذا دورنا، حتى وأن هم ملتزمين
احنا ندعم ونبغى يكون فيه تنافس
ونبغى يكون فيه أكثر من شركة
في نفس الوقت لا يكون فيه تنافس مضر
ويكون فيه دعم للصادرات السعودية وللتوظيف السعودي
هذا الهدف
هذه كانت يمكن مشكلة، وأنت جزاك الله خير وضحتها موضوع العنونة
المشكلة الثانية في موضوع تجربة العميل بشكل عام
فيه معاناة في سالفة طريقة التوصيل، نافذة التوصيل
ترى أنا بجيك من الساعة 6:00 الصباح إلى 6:00 المساء
هل المطلوب مني اثنا عشر ساعة أكون أنتظرك؟
فما هو واضح
أنا حاط العنوان
يكلمني لي واتساب ما أرد عليه؛ يرجع البضاعة
يرجعها المركز الرئيسي وأنا أقعد ألاحق
فصارت عبء لي
فتجربة العميل، أنت قلت: الموضوع انتقل لكم صار له سنتين، صح؟
إيه
من هيئة الاتصالات
نعم
بالنسبة للناس ما فرقوا كثير صراحة في تجربتهم
هو اللي صار الآتي
أول شيء، يُحسب بشكل كبير لمنظومة الاتصالات
أنها ما نقلت الملف إلا بعد إطلاق نظام
يساعد في حوكمة هذا السوق
لأن عشان تنجح أصلًا لازم تفهم آلية عمل الحكومة
عشان تقدر تشتغل بأريحية وتطبق العقوبات
لازم يكون النظام يدعمك
فهم قاموا بعمل كبير لإطلاق نظام ممتاز
يمكّن الهيئة المسؤولة عن الرقابة الأداء بعملهم
وبعدين أعطونا الملف
وكانت مبادرة منهم كتجربة ممتازة
الأرقام كلها إيجابية
أنا أعرف أن المستخدم يستنكر
صحيح
لكن إذا تشوف عندنا البيانات موجودة
مثل؟
نسبة التوصيل على الوقت أعلى بكثير
من قبل أربع سنوات أو ثلاث سنوات أو سنتين
بكثير ترى فوق 85% وهذا مرصود في مركز البيانات
وسرعة وصول الطلب
شوف ميزة الشعب السعودي أن دائمًا طموحه يرتفع
احنا لما نسافر برّا اليوم أوربا وللا
نعترض على كل شيء
من المطار للجوازات
أيش هذا؟ النت أيش فيه ضعيف؟
واحنا في لندن وللا في باريس وللا في سويسرا
لكن لو تسأل نفسك بصدق قبل ثلاث سنوات واليوم
لما تطلب على الإنترنت هل المدة نفسها؟
لا، عمر
أسرع بكثير، كنا أول ناخذ أربع أو خمسة أيام لوصول البضاعة
اليوم ممكن جدًّا تطلب من «نون» وللا من أمازون
وفي نفس اليوم توصل أو ثاني يوم
المدة الزمنية تحسنت
أعتقد أنا، وهذا كلامي دائمًا مع كل شركات التوصيل
تحسين الأنظمة مهم، وقاعدين يشتغلون عليه
والربط مع العنوان الوطني مهم
أنت الآن واجهتك مع الناس هما موظفي التوصيل
إذا ما هذول وصلوا للإحترافية
مهما أنت تجلس معي وتوريني خطط رائعة
إذا ما شمّرت ورفعت
عندي رأي قد يختلف معي ناس كثير
أنا أتوقع هذا راح يرفع التكلفة شوي
لكن أنا أتوقع ما راح يأثر على...
بالعكس أنا أتوقع المستخدم السعودي
التوصيل سبعة ريال وللا أربعة عشر ريال
ما تفرق معاه كثير للتسوّق عبر الإنترنت
يمكن معظمنا حتى ما يشوف تكلفة
هذه بتكون محل خلاف، قد لا يتفق معك كثير
محل خلاف حتى في النقاشات الداخلية
أنا مع رفع مستوى الخدمة وتقديم قيمة أعلى من التكلفة
إذا أنت اعتمدت على أدنى مستويات العمالة
وعشان التنافس شديد
وإذا حاولت ترفع غيرك بتخسر
لأن أنت عارف اللي ياخذ العقد مو المستخدم، مو أنا وأنت
اللي يعمل عقد التوصيل هو السوق الموزع أو شركة وسيط الشحن
هو اللي يعطي «آي مايل» ويعني «آرمكس» ويعطي «دي إتش إل» مو بأنا
أنا لو أقدر أختار الشركة اللي تريحني في التوصيل
وكانت سبعة ريال وللا أربعة عشر؛ بدفع أربعة عشر
والدليل على رأيي أن شركات توصيل الأغذية ماهي برخيصة
والأرقام مهولة
45% من حجم قطاع الـ «إف إم بي» في المملكة
يباع عن طريق تطبيقات توصيل الطعام
خمس تطبيقات 85% من ذلك
لما جينا نراجع تشريعات تطبيقات توصل الطعام
أي تعديل؛ أنا بأثر على كل قطاع الـ «إف إم بي»
عندنا 200 سائق رخصتهم...
عفوًا مرة ثانية، 45% من دخل المطاعم جاي من تطبيقات توصيل؟
نعم تطبيقات توصيل
أكثر من 500 ألف توصيل في اليوم، وغالي
أنت عارف التوصيل حق الشاورما اللي تطلبه
أغلى من التوصيل حق الطرد اللي يجيك من المطار وفسح
والناس ماهي مبسوطة من هذه الأسعار العالية
إيه، بس أنا أقول لك...
أقصد هي مثال على أيش؟ هي دليل على أيش؟
500 ألف توصيل في اليوم
معيلش أنا عندي البيانات أهم من الرأي
إذا الناس ماهي مبسوطة
ليش فيه هذا العدد؟
ليه 45% من حجم المبيعات؟
ترى ما شوفت دولة بهذه النسبة
500 ألف توصيل في اليوم!
حتى والله احنا كنا نناقشها
مع الازدحام اللي صاير؛ يستحق إعادة نظر
في نفس هذا السياق، أسولف مع واحد من المستثمرين في قطاع التوصيل
فأقول له: يا أخي ليش الجودة كذا؟ ليش قدراتهم؟
قال: أنا ما عندي استعداد أني استثمر، لأن يدي على قلبي
الوزارة ماهي معطيتنا توجه واضح
مرة بنسعود ومرة ما راح نسعود
مرة 7% ومرة 100%
مرة لازم موظفين الشركات
ومرة عادي العمالة السائبة اللي حاليًا موجودة
فالوزارة ما أعطت توجه واضح
فالمستثمر على أعصابه
ماهو قادر يحط فلوس ويطق صدره ويشتغل لبعيد
ليش ما حسمتوا الموضوع؟
أعتقد هذا الملف بالذات، احنا محظوظين
أن فيه خمس شركات تتحكم في 85% من حجم التوصيل
وهي الهيئة العامة للنقل المسؤولة عن هذا التشريع
لكن أنا أحضر الاجتماعات
المشكلة محددة بالأرقام
عندنا 200 ألف سائق برخصة سائق خاص
وهذا مخالف واضح، موجود اليوم
هذا مخالف للوائح، ولليوم موجود
لو ودنا نضر؛ كان مباشرةً هذا مخالف ونطبق عليه المخالفة
ونعرف الشركات، هي البيانات موجودة
عدد كبير من الشركات اللي يوصل لك اسمه «لؤي»
تشوفه ماهو بـ«لؤي»
واضح، أن هذا مخالف حتى لنظام الإقامة
إيه، اللي يُحسب أنا في نظري
حتى في العنوان الوطني أنا ما جيت لهذه النقطة في الأخير
ما بدأت الهيئة العامة للنقل في تطبيق المخالفات
أعلنت لائحة المخالفات لم تطبق
لأن فيه دروس مستفادة كانت من تطبيق
المخالفات الشديدة على الشاحنات
قرروا الآن أن أي مخالفة تكون في لجنة مستقلة
احنا نطلع على اللائحة، لكن مو موظفينا اللي يعطوا المخالفة
ونفس الشيء في العنوان الوطني طلعنا لوائح المخالفات
تم تشكيل اللجان، الآن راح تبدأ تطبيق المخالفات
لجان المستقلة يعطي شوية وزنية في تطبيق المخالفة
أنا أعلم يقينًا وأقولها في الشاشة
أن الخمس شركات الكبرى معنا في كل خطوة
أو مع الهيئة العاملة للنقل في كل خطوة من تطبيق التشريعات
أنا أختلف أن ما عرفنا أيش يبون
احنا قلنا لهم وين رايحين؟
قالوا لنا: انتظروا علينا سنتين، خلنا ندرّج هذه
واحنا ماشيين معهم
لما يكون قطاع فيه أربعين أو خمسين وللا ألف شركة صعب
لازم تبدأ تطبق وفيه خسرانين وكسبانين
هنا لأن فيه خمس شركات فقط
أنا أعلم يقينًا أنهم معنا
وعارفين أيش تبغون توصلون له
وعارفين أيش التحدي، وقالوا لنا: طيب هذه ما نقدر
قلنا لهم: ترى فيه تعديل في السوق لازم يصير
فهم معنا فيه
وبعضهم أفضل كمستوى سعودة، ومستوى حرص، ومشاركة بيانات
واضح بالنسبة لنا أن بعضهم أقوى من الآخر
فهذا أعتقد أن المشكلة لازم تنحل للشركات
أنا عندي أراء دائمًا في الاجتماعات الداخلية قوية
حتى على المستوى الاجتماعي هذه يبغى لها نظر الـ 500 ألف
أنت تشوف الزحمة في الرياض كيف
يبغى لها نظرة
هل هو هذا النتيجة الصحيحة الصحية
إذا بيزداد عدد سكان الرياض؛ أعتقد يبغى لها نظرة
ولو بنسوي الحين تصغير
ونتكلم على المشروع اللي أُعلن قبل أشهر قليلة
اللي هو موضوع مخطط المراكز اللوجستية
هو يمكن نقطة الوصل والربط بين كل هذه
القطاعات الأربعة أو الخمسة اللي سولفنا عنها، صحيح؟
صحيح
أيش هو المخطط العام؟
طبعًا المخطط العام أول مهمة جاتني لما جيت الوزارة
كان تبليغ من اللجنة العليا للخدمات اللوجستية
أن على الوزاة تعطينا مخطط عام للمراكز اللوجستية
عندنا مثال ممتاز جدًّا في المملكة
أنا أقولها دائمًا للفريق عندي
فيه كل يوم عندنا ملفات كبيرة
أقول الله يطرح البركة في عملنا أن بعد ما نمشي
بعد عشر سنوات أو عشرين سنة
ودائمًا أضرب لهم مثال بعدد من المشاريع من زمان
شوف اللي بنوا «الجبيل» و«ينبع»
شوف اللي كانوا أساس في تأسيس شركة «سابك»
شوف هيئة المدن الصناعية
يمكن هذيك كنت أسمع عنها أو اقرأ عنها الآن
هيئة المدن الصناعية أنا عشتها
أنا كنت في القطاع الخاص وكنا نستأجر من مدن
وكان مشاكل أفتكر أول
اليوم المدن الصناعية ممكّن كبير جدًّا جدًّا للمصانع
وعندها استقلالية مالية
أنا في مجلس الإدارة فعندي اطلاع
كل كم مصنع في الشهر قاعد يبدأ الآن وينطلق
فقلت لهم: الله يطرح البركة في عملنا
أن نخلق شيء اليوم
أنا أعرف أن نتيجته ما تبان بسرعة
أنه خلال عشر سنوات نقول
تنظيم هذا السوق المستودعات مهم وفيه قصص تبكي
بعطيك بعضها
أكبر مستودع لأمازون في جدة وين؟
وين؟
في ميناء جدة الإسلامي
أمازون هل تستخدم الميناء؟
لا
كله شحن جوي؟
شحن جوي وبري
مزعج جدًّا بالنسبة لي كلوجستي
أكبر مستودع لأمازون وحاليًا «أرامكس» كمان
في ميناء جدة الإسلامي، ليش؟
هذا المكان الوحيد المتاح فيه مستودعات؟
هذا المكان الوحيد اللي قدروا يأخذوا فيه استثناءات
لمستودعاتهم تطابق اللي هم يحتاجون
اشتراطات وزارة الشؤون البلدية والقروية للمستودعات ما تنطبق
فموظف الشؤون البلدية والقروية
ما عنده الصلاحية أن يغيّر، هذا نظام
وعشان تعدل النظام فيه مسار طويل عريض لازم تاخذه
فهو الآن يجلس معك ويفهم منك
أمازون، أنا كنت وقتها في القطاع الخاص
فانا اللي وقعت العقد
سبب المشكلة هو أنا
كان محاولة أني أساعد أمازون يجدون مستودع في جدة
نشرح أن هذه طريقة عملهم مختلفة
طريقة مكافحة الحريق مختلف
أنا أفهم تمامًا وأنا فني، بس ما عندي الصلاحية أعطيك استثناء
لكن لما راح الميناء
الميناء عندهم الأمن الصناعي
عندهم الصلاحية أنهم يأخذوا الاستثناء ويطبقون
لائحتهم تسمح بهذه المرونة
ميناء جدة الإسلامي مزدحم وفيه شاحنات، بقوم أجيب فيه...
هذا بس يعطيك حجم بالنسبة لي الألم
اللي موجود فيما يخص التشريعات
وهذا المجال يتطور بسرعة
مستودعات «بن زقر» في مدينة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية
كيف نظام مكافحة الحرائق عندهم؟
تدخل المستودعات ما فيه أكسجين
يعني حتى لو ولّعت ولاعة ما تولع معك
هذا مو موجود في أي لائحة اليوم
مستودعاتهم كلها ما في مساحات بين الأرفف، هذا مخالف
لكن مدينة الملك عبدالله الاقتصادية
عندهم من الفنيين والكفاءات ما يمكن تقييم ذلك
وتجربة الدول الأخرى في ذلك
وعندهم الصلاحية أنهم يعطوك
هل يفضّل أن يكون مستودع في مدينة الملك عبدالله
مقارنةً بجدة في ذيك الأوقات؟
يجوز، قد يكون أفضل له جدة في مرحلة من المراحل
يمكن المستقبل لكن يضطر يروح هناك
لأن هناك اللي أعطوه
فكان عندنا تنظيم كل كود البناء حق المستودعات
نقطة مهمة جدًّا
في مسار موازي للمراكز اللوجستية
أطلقنا نظام الخدمات اللوجستية
وفي الحكومة عشان تنجح؛ لازم تفهم كيف يشتغلوا
ففيه نظام وتنظيم ولائحة تفصيلية
النظام لازم يمر على مجلس الشورى
غير هيئة الخبراء وغير الموائمات
يمر على مجلس الشورى الموافقة، بعدين مجلس الوزراء
لأنه يكون فيه عقوبات ومخالفات
إذا ما في عقوبات ومخالفات؛ قد تكتفي بتنظيم
هو يمر بهيئة الخبراء وبعدين مجلس الوزراء مباشرةً
ما يحتاج أن يمر
احنا كنا نحتاج نظام الخدمات اللوجستية
فوائمنا مع وزارة الشؤون البلدية والقروية، هم معنا
فالمراكز اللوجستية هي ليست فقط مواقع
المستودع داخل المراكز اللوجستية قبيله واحد
بيكون الهيئة العامة للنقل
مثل ما «مدن» هي قبيل المصانع
الهيئة العامة للنقل عندها تنسيق مع وزارة الشؤون البلدية والقروية
عندها تنسيق مع الدفاع المدني
عندها تنسيق مع كل الجهات الأخرى
بس أسهل للمستثمر أن يتعامل مع جهة وحدة في اشتراطاته
عشان أتأكد أني فهمت
فالمراكز اللوجستية هي عبارة عن مواقع في الخريطة محددة
وأغلبها مستودعات، قبيلي هيئة النقل
آخذ رخصتي منها فقط ولا لي علاقة بالجهات الأخرى
نعم، رخصة البناء تجيك
تمامًا مثل النموذج التشغيلي لهيئة المدن الصناعية
احنا اتفقنا مع هيئة المدن الصناعية
فيه سبعة عشر منطقة صناعية
موقعها مناسب جدًّا تكون منطقة لوجستية
فقلنا هذا السبعة عشر خلها صناعية لوجستية
ما في حاجة أننا نستثمر في مكانين
وتصير تحت اشرافهم
تحت اشرافهم والتنسيق موجود
لكن من التسعة وخمسين شيل سبعة عشر
المتبقي؛ لا فيه بعضها تحت الهيئة الملكية للرياض
أو داخل حرم مطار أو داخل حرم ميناء
أيضًا هذه الجهات هي المسؤولة عن ترخيص ذلك
وأي ما هو دون ذلك خارج مناطق المطارات والموانئ
وخارج مدن الصناعية؛ هيئة النقل بتكون المسؤولة
وليش هذا الشيء مهم؟
أقصد ليش محتفلين بالخطوة هذه؟
أنتوا بس اعتمدتم مستودعات
إيه، احنا اعتمدنا كود البناء وهو تحدي عن كل...
كود البناء اللي أنشأناه الآن
يطبق في هيئة ملكية و للا في «مدن»
كود بناء واحد، وآلية استثناء واحدة
فمثل ما صار عندنا خارج المدن وداخل المدن
مشروع واحد طرحناه وشكلنا فريق فني
فيه كل هذه الجهات، وهم اللي وافقوا على المخرجات
واعتمدنا على اللي يسمونه «الرمز الأساسي»
بعدين تقدر كل جهة تضيف
مثلًا الرياض تبغى تضيفه لأنه الطراز «السلماني»
داخل المطار ودهم يكون فيه اشتراطات أمنية إضافية
بحقهم الإضافة، لكن على الأقل الأساس موحّد
وآلية استثناء موجودة
وهذه كانت نقطة كيف تكتبها في نظام
لكن لازم يكون فيه آلية استثناء لها لجنة موثقة
لأن القطاع يتطور
يمكن بكرة واحد يجيب «طائرة مسيرة» يسحب منه
أقول له: لا، استنى!
لازم يكون فيه عندي آلية، ناس فنيين
ويعلن ذلك للجميع: أن ممكن الكل يطبق نفسه
على سيرة يعلن، أنا أذكر قصة الناس راح تتفهمها
وحدة من المشاكل عندنا في مناطق الإيداع
احنا كان عندنا اثنين، اليوم وصلنا إلى إحدى عشر منطقة إيداع
اللي فيها إعفاء على البضاعة
أن في محلات تبيع تجارة إلكترونية من داخل منطقة الإيداع
فتخرج من الشركة إلى المستخدم
هذا أصلًا مستثنى من اشتراطات الغذاء والدواء
لأن ماهي رايحة للسوق
فلما «آيهرب» كانوا جايين للمملكة، مين اللي اعترض؟ «النهدي»
من أبسط حقوقه
قال: أنا عندي مصنع سعودي هنا، وقاعد ينتج
وكلمني سعادة الرئيس الله يذكره الخير
ورحت قابلته في جدة
قلت له: هم اليوم وهم في أمريكا يبيعوا 50 ألف شحنة في اليوم
ومن غير اشتراطات هيئة الغذاء والدواء
لأنها حسب النظام، تجارة إلكترونية تروح لمستخدم
وليست رايحة لسوق
ماهي كمية تجارية
فما راح تقدر تتغلب على هذه الموجة من هذا النوع
وإذا ما جاوا عندنا بيروحوا إلى الدولة الشقيقة ويكونوا أيضًا جنبنا
نصيحتي لك: أنت أبدأ بيع من الشركة للمستخدم من مصانعك
والمصنع حقك خليه بوندد
قدّم على الجمارك وحوّله بوندد
وفعلًا اليوم مصنع «النهدي» في جدة
أخذ ستة شهور لما اكتمل كله، والآن بدأ يبيع
فهذا مثال أن إذا أنت تشرّع قطاع اللوجستي
لحل المشاكل اليوم؛ أنت متأخر
لازم تكون فيه عندك المرونة للتشريع للمستقبل
ولازم يكون فيه مجال أصحاب الاختصاص
يقدروا يراجعوا حالة بعد حالة
وليس والله لائحة وحدة، وما فيها ...
اللهم يكون عندك شفافية في التعامل
وأي واحد ياخذ استثناء؛ تعلن ذلك الاستثناء وليش حصل عليه
والآخرين يكون عندهم
هذه المرونة أعتقد اللي ما عنده إياها؛ ما راح ينجح
ويمكن أبو عمر لو احنا بنلّخص كل هذه الرحلة
بأننا نتكلم عن: هذه كلها بُنى تحتية وأنظمة قاعدين نهيئها
عشان مستقبلًا مشروع مثل الممر الاقتصادي
أو طريق «الحزام والحرير»
تجي وتبني على هذه البنية التحتية الموجودة
فنبغى نختم الحلقة بلمحة عن هذه المشروعين
هل هم متنافسين؟ هل هم متضادين لازم واحد منهم؟
هل هم شيء مستقل؟ وللا هم بناء على الموجود؟
لو تشرح لنا بس عن هذه المشروعين
اللي هي الممر الاقتصادي
وطريق «الحزام والحرير»
اللي هو برضه يمر في «جيزان» أو شيء مثل كذا
خلني آخذ نظرة شوي أبعد
حجم التجارة بين الشرق والغرب
هناك ست مسارات سككية موجودة أو جاري العمل عليها
وهناك يمكن ثلاث مسارات بحرية
أقوى مسار بحري كحجم وتكلفة ومدة
البحر الأحمر، وقناة «السويس»
فيه من حول إفريقيا وفيه من شمال روسيا مسارين آخرين
لكن ما في أحد يوازي هذا
السككي لا؛ فيه إيران لروسيا، فيه العراق الآن إلى تركيا
ما في شك أن فيه تنافس بين «الحرير» وبين الممر الاقتصادي
أعتقد لوجستيًا ما في تنافس كبير
أعتقد قوة ناعمة
وسياسيًا فيه تنافس
من كل القراءات حجم الاقتصاد ونموه في الصين
وحجم الاقتصاد ونموه في الهند
واحنا حجم الاقتصاد والنمو عندنا في المملكة
وهذا واحنا لسنا ما فكّينا الدول اللي حولنا
احنا بالفعل في اختناق
بالفعل اليوم كل المسارات المتاحة في اختناق
قناة «السويس» في اختناق
أنا أفكر 2030-2040 احنا بعيدين عن الكفاءة الكافية
هي سبحان الله القنوات اللوجستية كل ما وسعتها؛ تعبّت
هي سبحان الله ممكّنة
الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل عام قاعد ينمو
عدد البشر ينمو، عدد البضائع المتبادلة ينمو
نعم، وفيه أحيانًا لما يكون فيه اختناق؛ ترتفع أسعار معينة
أنت كمان ما ودك تعيق
شوف المملكة العربية السعودية سواءً رايح من البحر الأحمر
سواءً من سكة الحديد
سواءً من سكة الحديد اللي هو طالع من عند العراق
كلها احنا مشبوكين فيها
موقعنا ممتاز وقدرتنا على التأثير في القرار ممتازة
وتواصلنا معهم كله ممتاز
وعندنا ترى دفع
أنا أذكر في المجلس السعودي العراقي
يرأسه معالي الدكتور «ماجد القصبي»
كنا ندفع بزيادة حجم الصادرات
كنت أرجع فخور، زدنا 20%
فأرجع أقول للمعالي الدكتور: معاليك أبشرك ارتفعت الصادرات 20%
قال: هذه طايحة من كرسي وللا أيش
لا تجيني ما أبغى أقابلك، يا معاليك!
اليوم هي عشر أضعاف قبل سنة ونص حجم...
فهذه ولسه احنا في بداية المشوار في منفذ
الآن فيه منفذ آخر
وفيه ربط سككي بالكويت ومن ثم للعراق وقِس على ذلك
أنا رحت جيبوتي أكثر من مرة
حتى جيبوتي فيه قصة أنا نفسي كذا أقولها
عشان أنتقم من معالي «الرميح» رئيسي
معاليه طبعًا هو شديد ولكنه راعي نكت
وأنا أحب «الفورملا ون» بشكل كبير جدًّا
أتابعها من عشرين سنة
فعادةً هو دائمًا، لؤي اسمع اطلع جيبوتي
قلت له: سم
أداني التاريخ
قلت له: لحظة لا، فيه سباق «فورملا» في جدة، مستحيل أجي معك
قال لي: أيش «فورملا ون» لا، تجي معي
قلت له: أسأل الوكيل المساعد، ترى يعرف جيبوتي
قال لي: لا، تجي أنت معي
معاليك طيب أجلها يومين، قدمها يومين؛ أنا حاضر
لا، طبعًا رحت غضبان صراحة، كنت منزعج
أنا أحب «الفورملا» حب وعشق
وجات في جدة، يعني ما تتفوّت
أيوة، أروحها كل سنة. وتلاقيني أشرح لكل أحد
هذا الكفر ما أدري أيش، وهذه «الفنتوري» حقت...
أحب القطاع هذا
رحنا جيبوتي، ما بقى أحد ما قال له
هذا لؤي وكيل الخدمات اللوجستية
وكان مايبي يجي بيحضر «الفورملا»
قدام وزراء وقدام مسؤولين
والله العظيم، إلا جاني اتصال أن رئيس الوزراء وده يقابلنا
فكلمني معالي الدكتور قال لي: اسمع جانا اتصال بنروح
قلت له: أنا عندي شغل هنا
والله خفت أروح
يقول
إيه يقول ما بقى أحد
حقيقة الأمر هناك دفع كبير من سمو سيدي
بزيادة حجم التبادل التجاري
شوف هو اتخاذ القرار عنده واضح
أيش المشاركة في الناتج المحلي؟
الميزان التجاري، التكلفة الإجمالية
وكم منها على الدولة السنوات القادمة
والمحتوى المحلي
يسألك عن هذه الأشياء
وأحيانًا يسألك كم ترتيبنا بين الدول
خلاص اتخاذ القرار لازم يكون مجهز له هذه المعلومات كاملة
و هو سموه دقيق جدًّا في وصف الهدف
بعدين يتركك تشتغل براحتك
لكن يتابع معك أول شيء، أيش الهدف؟ لازم يكون واضح
سبحان الله، دائمًا يشرح
والله فيه أكثر من موقف كذا أستغرب
ما يقول: أبغى كذا
أبغى كذا عشان
ليش، دائمًا عنده حاضر
أبغى هذا عشان؛ واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة، أربعة
ليش؟ لأن أنت مو دائمًا عندك وصول
مو دائمًا عندك القدرة على الاجتماع معه
لما يشرح لك طريقة تفكيره وكيف وصل إلى هذا الاستنتاج
يساعدك أنت إذا كان عندك سؤال
ما يحتاج تضطر ترجع
هو شرحها أول ليش؟
فهنا أطبّق هذا على هذا
وعنده حضور وعلى الموضوع اللوجستي
أذكر مرة كان النقاش في البحر الأحمر
فجأة في وسط الاجتماع لنا أربع ساعات مجتمعين
وتشعبت المواضيع، وكل وزير يقول رأي
فمسك البحر الأحمر من أقصى
وكان رمضان وصايمين
من أقصى نقطة لأقل نقطة
هذه الـ 150 كيلو تسووا فيها كذا كذا
من هنا لهنا مع جامعة الملك عبدالله «كاوست» تسوون مدري أيش
من هنا لهنا هذه مع هيئة تطوير الرياض أبغى فيها كذا كذا
مسك البحر الأحمر والله من أعلى نقطة
ما كانت من ضمن هذا، كان الموضوع شوي مختلف
بس يعطينا خجل، أنا أخرج من الاجتماع
مو معقول كل المسؤوليات اللي عنده ويعرف البحر الأحمر أكثر مني
ماهو مقبول
لذلك لما كنت تسألني أول عن الضغط
هذا المسؤولية، لأن ما ودك في يوم
أنت المفروض في قطاعك أفهم واحد، وبعدين هو ...
لما مسكها، رجعت للفريق عندي
وقلت: لحظة، احنا ترى ما احنا في المستوى
ما أبغى يوم أروح وأكون أعرف أقل
تذكر حكيتك مرة قصة اللي كنا في عرض
والحمد لله كل عروضي مع سمو سيدي تم الموافقة على توصيات
ما في ولا مرة، تسع مرات تقريبًا
لكن فيه مرات كان فيه تأنيب
مرة منهم كان يسألني من الخمسة الأشياء اللي قلت لك
فيه واحدة كانت ناقصة
فسألني، أنا عارف الإجابة بس 90%
وهنا يغتفر الخطأ أنك تكون منت جاهز
لكن لا يُغتفر خطأ أنك تقول معلومة غير صحيحة
فقلت له: سيدي ماني متأكد
قام، قال: كيف كذا وكيف تخلوني آخذ قرار، وما في المعلومة كاملة
قلت له: لا، ما بناخذ وقت
قال: يعني كم؟
قلت له: أسبوع طال عمرك
قال: أسبوع! أنا فاضي كل شوية أقعد أرجع لكم
ونرجع نعرض الموضوع، لازم تجوني جاهزين، لازم تكونوا مستعدين
كان غضبان صراحة جدًّا
فهو في غضبته، قلت له: سيدي قبل ما يخلّص الاجتماع
أنا عارف أن ثاني بند، لسه ورائي بنود كثير
قلت له: قبل لا يخلّص الاجتماع
قال: يلا توكل على الله
وخرجت برّا، والحمد لله المعلومة كانت موجودة
ورجعنا وعرضناها وتم قبول التوصية
ودائمًا أقول: الحمد لله بعدها كل الاجتماعات
كان بيّض الله وجيهكم
لكن هو في طريقة اتخاذ القرار واضح جدًّا
ما في عذر أنك تروح...
وهذا يضع عليك دائمًا في كل مسؤولياته
طالما هو أستخدم من وقته لك
وواضح أنه يعرف الملف بشكل جيد
من غير اللائق أنك...
أنا في القيادة هذا الدرس يجعلنا كلنا مع الفريق
والله لا أحد يفكر في راتب، ولا أحد يفكر في نوم
طالما هذا الهدف واضح
طالما أرجع أقول له: زدنا 20%
معالي «القصبي» يقول: طيحها من الكرسي
واضح وين الهدف من معالي الوزير، من معالي «أبو نواف»
الهدف واضح، والكل يعمل بكل طاقته
واتخاذ القرار واضح كيف آليته
يعطينا كلنا مسؤولية أن ما ينفع نخذل أو نقصّر
واللي يشعر أنه ما يقدر
يجب أن يترك المجال لغيره أن يكمل المسيرة
فأنا أقول لك: على تعداد السكان اللي صاير
وعلى حجم الاستثمار الداخلي
وعلى التغييرات التشريعية وعلى البنية التحتية
أنا القطاع اللوجستي متفائل فيه
يعرفوني الشباب دائمًا
وكل أرقامنا واحنا لسه ما أنشأنا المنطقة الحرة
يمكن أختم بهذه، أنا في مجلس إدارة المنطقة الحرة في الرياض
الطلبات اللي جاتنا أكبر بكثير من مساحة الأرض
اللي هي في المطار؟
إيه، اللي جانب المطار
أكثر بكثير من مساحة الأرض
احنا لسه قاعدين نبني البنية التحتية
وقعنا مع أربع أو خمس شركات
منهم: «آيهرب» و«شلهوب» و«أبل» طبعًا ومنهم «شي إن»
بس فيه «بوينق» تبي، «هك كونكشن» تبي
المحطات كثيرة
واحنا هذه أول منطقة حرة ننشئها
واحنا اشتراطاتنا كبيرة في القبول
غيرنا ممكن وأنا جالس معك، أسوي شركة عنده
وما في أي اشتراطات وفيه مخالفات كثيرة
لا، لازم تضمن لي حجم معين ولازم معيار معين وغيرها
فأنا لذلك متفائل دائمًا
والمناطق الحرة اللي أُعلنت
بتشوفون والناس بتشوف كيف بتشتغل إن شاء الله
بانتهاء البنية التحتية لها
متى تنتهي حق المطار؟
حق المطار هذه السنة تنتهي، وبدأنا نأجر
هي هذه أكثر واحدة ماشية بشكل جيد
لكن هي مدينة الملك عبدالله و«جيزان» و«رأس الخير»
لسه، أتوقع سنة أو أقل الين ما يبدأ التأجير
وإن شاء الله لما ننتهي المخطط الرئيسي الرياض وجدة
وتُعتمد منطقتين الحرة هناك
مع الربط السككي مع ربط الموانئ
مع التكامل الخدمات ومع المراكز اللوجستية
أنا متفائل إن شاء الله بشكل كبير لهذا
أنت أول وكيل وزارة للخدمات اللوجستية
وهذا القطاع يمكن السنتين الماضية شاهد حراك كبير
وأنت الآن تغادر هذا القطاع أو تغادر هذا المنصب
وتنتقل للطرف الآخر اللي هو القطاع الخاص
اللي يتأثر بقرارات الحكومة وسياساتها واجراءاتها
أبغى أختم الحوار بأكثر بذرة أنت فخور أنك زرعتها
من إصلاح أو قرار أو مشروع أو تنظيم إلى آخره
وأكثر مشروع كنت متحمس أنك تسويها أول ما تطلع
بس أنه ما تم
البذرة هذه شخصية جدًّا
ولكن أنا لما بدأت الوكالة كنت الموظف الوحيد
اليوم الخمسة وأربعين موظف في الوكالة
شباب وبنات، من الشمال، الجنوب، الشرق ومن الغرب
من القطاع الخاص ومن القطاع الحكومي
من الصغار في السن، أربع أو ثلاثة سنوات خبرة إلى عشرين سنة خبرة
وفوقها من قطاع البحري للجوّي
أنا متأكد تمامًا
وبان الفرق أصلًا اليوم
كان الديوان لما يطلب، وللا أي طلبات دراسة
كنت أطوّل الين ما أقدر أجمع المعلومة، الآن دائمًا
فأنا مؤمن بالعمل المؤسسي، مؤمن ببناء القدرات
الفريق عندي يقوم اليوم بـ 99% من العمل
أنا صرت فقط الممثل
اللي أمثل المنظومة في الاجتماعات واللجان المختلفة
اليوم مؤتمر البريد استضافته السعودية بالتصويت
هو قائم، يمكن بعد إعلان الحلقة يكون منتهي
رئيسة المؤتمر، مدير عام السياسات عندنا في الوكالة
الأستاذة «جيهان السعيد» خريجة قانون من جامعة «دوك»
ماهي كبيرة في السن، خبرتها تسعة سنوات
أول سيدة ترأس مؤتمر بريدي
وشوفها ما شاء الله الآن ثلاثة أيام نقاشات قانونية صعبة جدًّا
لأن قرارات المؤتمر مؤثرة على كل قطاع البريد العالمي
وتشوف إدارة الحوار
ما بقي أحد في المؤتمر ما يشكرنا ويشكرها
هذا الفريق هو أكثر شيء أنا
هذا على المستوى الشخصي أكثر شيء أنت فخور فيه
على المستوى الشخصي
بس أهم إصلاح جوهري بيفرق في مستقبل السعودية اللوجستية
ما فيه شك المراكز اللوجستية
المراكز اللوجستية، هذا أهم مشروع؟
هذا أهم مشروع
أيش المشروع اللي تمنيت تسويه قبل ما تمشي، بس ما صار؟
الموضوعين اللي كنت أبغى أقفلها قبل ما أمشي
اللي هي مواقف الشاحنات عند مداخل المدن؛ تأخرت فيها شوي
ومطار الرياض تأخرت فيه
قريبين إلى قلبي ويعرفون كل المسؤولين
على مدى الضغط اللي أنا أقوم فيه في ذلك
لكن كلاهما الآن له خطة
أطبطب على نفسي، أن على الأقل تركتهم في مسار
إن شاء الله أنه واضح
الواحد في آخر أيام يتمنى أنه ...
أنا علاقتي ممتازة بالوزراء وعلاقتي ممتازة بالقطاع الخاص
بس أنا أتمنى أنهم يذكروني بالخير في سرهم
لأن أعرف أعلنهم دائمًا العلاقة ممتازة
بس أتمنى أنهم يذكروني بالخير
هذا هو المكسب
هم الحكم الحقيقي على مدى نجاح الوكالة من عدمها
شكرًا أبو عمر سعداء أنك شرفتنا في هذه الحلقة
ومتفائلين أن هذه الإصلاحات اللي تمت
تخلينا محور ربط القارات
الله يعافيك وقواكم الله
شكرًا لك، تسلم يا أبو عمر
مع السلامة
شكرًا لكم وشكرًا لفهد القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
ياسر آل غانم في إدارة التصوير
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
ياسر كدشة مساعد إضاءة
في تسجيل الصوت عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج رزان الدهيثم وأصيل بافرط
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
اشتركوا في القناة